So glad you're here,
man.
Thank you Rebecca.
Please fucking pumped.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the flashlight
and enter in the code named Rogan,
you will save yourself 15 percent.
How's that time?
I read a good deal.
I have a flashlight on me right now.
Do you?
Did he have one yesterday?
Have a flow state that leads me to where
I keep my flashlight to a little case in
my house.
I'll give you one little bit.
Leave.
I don't need it,
but I've got plenty of.
Hey,
I'm making a good living.
Expensive.
Thank you.
And I'm not shy.
You're not a shy guy.
If you wanted one you would just buy it.
No,
no.
Joe was using that earlier.
No one used that.
We wouldn't do that to.
He's done that to other people.
I would not allow him to do that.
Sure.
Come on dog.
You know,
I love you mom.
I love you.
Like I love air.
The,
uh,
we're also brought to you by onnit.com.
Makers of Alpha brain,
the nootropic supplement,
if you're interested in any of this
stuff,
I suggest to you a checking out our
website,
a on it o n n I t.com,
and be just google nootropics and read
all the pros and cons on.
Don't just go out there and buy
something,
but if you're interested in our stuff,
it's a full spectrum neutral.
It's all balanced out and explained
online and as much technical and
scientific details we can.
We're actually funding studies on this
right now and we're hoping that it was
going to be done at Boston University's,
uh,
if it's not,
the other option I think was university
of Australia,
one of the universities in Australia
that doesn't work.
Columbus state to find some closure
option.
We're going to Australia find some
Komodo island dudes that are selling
certificates.
Um,
it's,
uh,
we have 100 percent money back
guarantee.
This is the most important thing,
but when you go through the do anything,
the money back,
it's not worth it.
Some people,
it is.
First of all,
what does the supplement do for you?
The supplement is a cognitive enhancing
supplement.
Don,
my rarer,
it makes your mind function a little bit
better,
a little neuro cup of coffee if you what
we're just talking about.
I forgot the to Rita.
That's not what we're talking about.
We're talking about vitamins.
You dirty bitch vitamins and discounts
and the fact that you could send it back
and you get 100 percent of your money
back.
Can you take 100 percent?
Can you drink with them?
Oh yeah,
it's a vitamin.
I just always ask a doctor whenever it
gives me something.
There are certain nutrients that they've
discovered,
you know,
that help Alzheimer's patients are
nutrients that help people after they've
had some head trauma.
That was what a Roman ascii stuff was
based on.
I know you're a big football fan,
Bill Roman ask.
He has his own very similar line of this
kind of stuff.
He's got something called neuro one,
which I also like and maybe some people
might like even better than Alpha brain
because it's a drink and you'll like it.
You could just mix it up like some
people don't like swallowing pills.
I don't give a fuck.
I take two Alpha brains and I'm
straight.
I like it.
You like it up?
Yeah,
just for lips.
Just for giggles and were just first
story,
like Shit's bad than the good surprises.
I never did this positive,
but you know what?
I met Romanowski in Denver with the
Broncos retraining and Haley Colorado
and they told me I wanted to interview
him.
I said the show called off.
So it was essentially.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And they said you don't want an
interview with bill.
And I said,
no,
I do.
So we got to lunch.
The whole place is filled.
There's a table for eight.
It's empty with just him sitting there.
It's not crazy because nobody wanted to
eat lunch with them.
Wow.
I've talked to him subsequently saying,
sounds cool man.
The dude had a ton of concussions.
Yeah,
a ton of concussions.
And that was the reason why he created
this neuro Juana.
I watched a whole interview with him
about it.
Fascinating stuff.
You know,
the guy realized that he was having
problems and he tried to counteract that
with nutrients.
And so that's uh,
I was taught this by a first exposed to
his stuff by no name from a member of
Sara and no name on it.
Yeah,
he did.
I did two for Wella.
It's just a joke.
He did.
Yeah,
he did.
San Fran did it for a job.
Who's pis?
I drank my own.
I wasn't going to drink anybody else.
I'll let may.
Maybe a dominatrix now.
How dare you.
Dumb you dirty boy last night.
Anyway,
check out just a free plug for Mr.
Roman [inaudible].
I enjoyed his stuff.
Check out neuro one.
If you want to check out our stuff,
go to [inaudible] dot com.
We have one in it,
not just Alpha brain,
which is something that I use everyday.
And again,
as I said,
it's 100 percent money back guarantee on
the first order.
You don't have to 30 pills,
can't like get a big giant bottle.
And then the Newbie,
but 30 pills,
the first 30 pill bottle,
it's,
we want to make sure that no one feels
ripped off.
Does I use this stuff?
I've used this stuff way before I was,
uh,
you know,
associated with on it.
I believe nootropics are a,
an effective way to give yourself a
little mental edge.
And I also believe in regular vitamins.
I tell people I drink a kale shakes.
I tried to do it every single day.
It's big,
crazy mixture of Greens.
I take all sorts of vitamins.
I say take all sorts of antioxidants.
I try to drink as much Kombucha as I
can.
I take as Adopolis.
I take a lot of like healthy live
cultures and I absolutely know for a
fact by my own personal experience that
that's enhanced my life.
Was the guy that just had an astronomy
sandwich can put that shit away.
I put that shit away.
You know why?
Because I'm going to do kettle bells two
hours.
What's a head toothpaste that's.
I have these giant iron cannonballs that
swing around.
I got to show it to you.
You'll love it.
So craziest exercise ever is this
Russian strength training where you,
you're,
you're swinging around these fucking
giant cannon balls.
So every movement is a compound movement
that requires your whole body to work as
one unit.
So it transfers very well athletically.
Look,
did you Jitsu or to football or even
about,
you know,
you're a good basketball player.
It would transfer even at that.
If it's kettlebells,
like one of the best exercises I've ever
used ever.
So fucking it's the.
It's a great way to work out.
It's brutal and you can get done in 20
minutes.
You can just blow it out in 20 minutes
and then you're fucking wrecked for two
days.
It's amazing.
It's so good.
It's such a good exercise.
I was hoping maybe we just shoot a
little pool buddy.
We're going to do that for sure.
Anyway,
back to the commercial on a.com.
Go check out Alpha brain checkout.
There's a shroom tech sport which is a a
quarter steps mushroom,
be 12 and a bunch of other stuff in
their supplement for endurance,
which cordyceps mushroom is.
It's actually a nutrient that people
started eating at high altitudes and
help them deal with the lack of oxygen
and they believed that it helps in
difference and especially when combined
with be 12 people love it.
A lot of Jujitsu guys love the shroom
tech sport.
I get that all the time and shroom tech
immune is another one that's also a
mushroom based supplement that actually
enhances your immune system.
So fascinating concept.
The way it works,
being that it tricks your body into
thinking.
It's like cold,
so your body fires up a domain system
for a fight that never takes place.
Coca leaves before I go into the
Hollywood hills.
It's a good move because of the
altitude.
You get those,
you know go.
Yeah,
I know some.
Some Bolivians can't grow.
That shit here is.
Can you grow it here?
If you have a greenhouse at work and
grow anything.
Why the fuck?
Why don't they have greenhouse?
They.
I never saw green here.
Why's everybody grown?
Coke in the third world.
When you just get a nice greenhouse.
Yeah.
Is it like undercover?
My blowing up their spot right now.
I probably shouldn't be talking about
this on a.com.
Oh,
and it go check out all the shit.
New Moods,
a five htp,
tryptophan enhancing.
I'll supplement and entering the code
named Rogan and you will get 10 percent
off all your orders and remember always
the first order of 30 pills.
If you don't like everything,
it's bullshit.
It's not for you.
Whatever.
Whatever you feel you can get 100
percent of your money back.
You don't even have to return the
product.
We're way more concerned with people not
feeling ripped off than we are with
making money.
All right.
I have a question.
Try to keep it on the level of their
show with this commercial.
This is over commercials over and then
we go on for like two hours just
talking.
Shit.
Ready?
Why don't we have lunch together?
Talked about everything.
What are you doing,
Brian?
Nothing.
What happened?
You slipped.
You.
Are you a Dj now?
I am in now.
You've been hanging out with Russell
Peters.
I have been.
All right.
Give Gimme some doctors.
Scratch Gimme something.
We've got to have Nick Diaz.
Yeah.
I don't think you should do that
anymore.
I don't think that's.
I don't like that.
I want to hear Nick Diaz voice and Nick
Diaz is one of the fighters in the UFC
guy.
Really the coolest thing ever.
He want to fight.
Then after the fight he goes,
train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Greatest moment of my program experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
This guy likes fucking around with the
speeds of things.
Let's go get some technological age
going on.
Welcome to the show and thank you.
So happy to have you here.
Dominant a railroad just before,
just to all you folks out there in the
cyber world is a guy that I actually
paid to see before I got into comedy.
I was a huge fan and uh,
I,
I just,
I love standup comedy.
I loved watching evening at the Improv
and I took a date to the,
uh,
to Nick's comedy stop and Boston to
watch dahmer.
I think maybe I had done an open mic
like maybe once,
maybe I might not have even.
It might've even been before,
but I remember I watched there and one
of the things you,
you,
uh,
first of all,
you,
you were,
you fucking killed and you were one of
the few guys that could survive that
crazy Boston gauntlet that they used to
throw it on the national head,
but they liked me and so everybody loved
you.
But it was a,
it was a tricky situation that Boston
gauntlet taste through.
It would take a guy like billy crystal
would come into town,
right?
And they would make billy crystal.
They would purposely put up the best
local guys.
Steve Sweeney,
Don Gavin,
Kenny,
everybody would go up with 15 minutes.
I'll fucking fury to short sets and
you're supposed to do 50 at the end and
then,
you know,
at the end.
But first of all,
they've made everyone laugh with every
local reference humanly possible.
And if there's anything people love in
Boston,
it's a Boston joke.
It's a problem.
I had like my first 20 minutes all
revolved around Boston because when
you're,
when you're fucking sinking out there
and you're looking for some,
you know that you could make fun of a
girl from revere.
She has big hair.
That's right there.
It's in my.
It's in my wheelhouse.
I can pull that out.
You know,
you could always go with like local
Charleston,
the Irish girls and all that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was.
There's always something like,
well,
and then you're in Japan after dark
Spanish.
Yeah.
You could.
You could do like local jokes and you
survived.
You survived.
You're one of the few guys.
I saw a lot of guys eat up fat bag of
dicks.
I heard Richard Lewis hid under the
stage afterwards.
Oh,
I heard.
He said,
well,
I've heard that a few times with that
guy.
He's apparently,
if he doesn't get like his crowd,
like he has a very specific crowd that
like comes up to see them and sometimes
you know,
people maybe don't know what he's going
to do before he does it.
If they do,
they love it.
They love that character.
But if they don't,
I think from what I've heard,
it can go bad.
I can imagine.
Remember Nick's,
Nick's was the place where you saw me
and that was really a tough club and
especially the third show in Friday
night.
So I asked Jonathan Katz due to show
with me,
you know,
how Jonathan
is very nebbishy and little Jewish
comedian versus a hosted my first open.
Like,
what was he?
Yeah,
it was nice.
Theoretical,
right?
Yeah.
And he,
uh,
I said John did a show at me.
He goes,
I can't,
I can't go in there.
I said,
come on,
I'll protect you.
You know,
watch your back.
She goes up.
They actually started heckling the back
of his bald head before he got to the
stage for nothing.
He didn't say anything.
He goes up,
it goes a precisely,
just walks off the stage.
They booed him before he talked.
I love the.
Boston was an interesting mix of college
educated people and savages.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it is one of the,
it has,
I think has the highest amount of
colleges per capita in the country.
And I couldn't get in any of them in
our.
I used to see street fights there when,
when you didn't see them anymore,
you see guys,
they didn't go home and work at a tie
white shirt hanging out.
Oh yeah.
Battling each other.
There's still fights in Boston.
Boston dudes will still fight.
It's one of the few places where you're
probably not going to get shot.
No,
I actually want to duke it out with
Mike.
Get stomped.
Well,
you could get shot though.
Everyone has baseball bats,
but no one plays bass with the wrong
kids from south that you could get shot.
Anybody get shot there too.
But you do definitely see like more
fistfights there.
Yeah.
I always think of you as in New York
while I was born in Jersey.
But uh,
I mean I got better in New York when I
was in,
but I developed in Boston,
but I was only there for four years
doing stand up,
you know,
I moved to New York only four years into
my act was.
And I got a manager so that my manager,
who's still my manager,
so state it was selling me as a
headliner,
but I wasn't really a headliner yet.
You didn't have the minutes.
You probably had the talent.
But I had a good solid 15 to 40 if the
ground was right.
Remember the first time this guy,
Hiram cast and crew,
I remember that guy got me a Gig for a
$75.
I had to do 45 minutes.
I said I only have 25.
He goes like,
you know,
like Jesus with the fishes that goes,
go out there and do it.
It will come.
It will come unto thee.
And I don't know if it came you crowd
work because I didn't have the time.
Oh yeah.
Those are silly days.
I couldn't believe people can do 20
minutes.
When I had five minutes,
I got up 20 minutes in a row.
They don't.
What's the longest flat out set of?
Just stand up you've ever done?
I'm not a real good at real long.
I probably an hour and a half.
That's about all you should do,
right?
I think I love a 45 minutes set crusher.
Right.
Just get off one them wanting more
instead of.
Yeah,
I've done long.
I've done too long.
I used to do these q and a's at the end
of my shows.
Yeah,
but that's different.
I thought that goes into some.
Nan was getting to sample,
used to do the people were falling
asleep or bored.
They get bored or girlfriends are like,
yeah,
you know,
it's.
You can only taught nobody.
I don't care who are.
Maybe it was Charlie Murphy that said
this.
It might've been.
Oh No.
His job did Charlie Murphy quota before
I quote him all the time.
Get to know Charlie Murphy.
He's a deep dude because he really.
I don't know.
He said deep dude.
He says some pretty interesting shit.
He's a great storyteller too.
He's a good guy around Charlie.
You would like Charlie Murphy.
Dom.
You would like.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
It's always weird for those guys whose
brothers like Tony Rock,
Chris Rock's brother Tony Rockets.
Fuck,
he's great.
Yeah,
he's fucking funny,
man.
I hadn't seen him in years and uh,
I saw him at the Improv and I had to go
up to them afterwards.
I got,
dude,
I haven't seen you in like a long time.
Like I go,
God damn.
You got good man.
Winton is it that makes you laugh?
Yeah.
Just some goofy in front of you with
smart,
friendly on stage too,
like fun on stage.
Like you want to hang out with them.
I just want to have fun with them.
You know,
when you get to see a guys enjoying
themselves up there,
it really makes you see when a guy's not
anymore.
It's one of the saddest things about our
business.
When you see a guy who's just doesn't
even realize what he's got the greatest
job of all time.
I know the other night I was late for
work and I work 15 minutes and it was at
10:00
at night.
I was taking a nap.
I was fucking late for work and I'm such
a hamper.
Fag that I was in the bathtub.
I'm so lazy.
I was shaving.
I was took a bath so I didn't have to
stand in shape,
but it's almost like they're calling me
on the,
on the cell phone thinking I wasn't
showing.
And you're right around the corner.
Oh,
that's a real comic.
There's something about Comedians
stripper time,
but I love it.
You know,
it's like people need help.
People try and make it miserable,
but it's got to be tough.
Huh?
Ain't tough compared to like work in a
coma,
but going on the road,
I'd hate to be on the road all the time
on going.
Nobody's asking you.
Nobody's ask Yo,
hey,
I hate to fly to Australia.
Nobody wants you in Australia.
What are you going to do when you get
there?
You know what I mean?
Like people ever get people to try and
make your life miserable.
Trying to like maybe make themselves
feel better about themselves.
Yeah,
there's definitely people that was
trying to justify why they're happier
than you and find the holes in your
game.
But as a professional comedian,
as long as you stay funny and the only
way to stay funny,
you just keep doing what you're doing.
You'll never become a crazy person.
Keep reading shit,
keep writing,
shed.
Keep watching things.
Keep coming up with new jokes.
You're always going to keep doing it.
Yeah,
but I mean I see guys like my age are so
bitter.
Bitter.
You fucking got away with life.
Being a comedian.
I though,
you know,
it's like I love it.
I want to get better.
Well you're a,
you're a real comic.
Felt dumb.
You've always been a real comic.
Like the.
As long as I've known you,
you know,
like I said,
I paid to see you before I ever even did
it.
Really.
You've always been a just like that's
what you are.
You're not like a guy who is trying to
get a series and if you got that series
in,
you'd abandoned stand up or a guy to be
able to.
You always just domino,
rarer professional comedian from
television.
Even introduce yourself like that.
Television doing well.
You know like I was wanting to Suzanne
somers show when I came out here and I
really liked her.
The show is really bad.
It's called cheese to sheriff.
She used to share.
Oh No.
Beautiful Blonde with big tits and she's
a sure that you get that Gig and uh,
at the end of the night they'd always
want to go out.
I go,
I gotta go to the comedy store and they
go,
well,
why you already have a job?
I don't know.
That's my job.
This is my side job,
you know what I mean?
Being in the building of the Sitcom was
my side job,
my real job is being a standup like,
and that's the way I take it.
Like even anytime I got series or
anything else and I love acting,
I love working with people,
but I lost the standups.
My favorite.
It's the most fun thing ever.
We used to talk about it after when I
was doing a news radio,
you know,
I'd come back to the store and you'd be
like,
yeah,
there's nothing.
Doesn't matter what you're doing.
I still want to go up there and kill.
I remember we talked about it because I
remember because you were getting the
series because I always practiced stand
up.
Oh yeah,
Daniel Tosh that because he's on top
with the comedy central thing.
But he practiced the standups and
wouldn't you know what happens when you
get fired from a series?
We still got our job.
Right?
How cool is that?
Yeah.
The last thing you want to do.
I don't like being dependent on
anything.
That's why I was so nice not having a
boss.
Yeah.
Well the best boss I've ever had for
sure is the USA because they're there.
They couldn't be better people to work
for.
I mean,
my eyes.
I've never had it.
I've never seen you so happy.
I love it.
Has Been.
You're so good at that.
You're so fucking sharp and,
and like you make it.
Like I was telling you,
you break it down,
you know,
you make me understand the fighting more
while I try to explain it is if like
you're smart friend is over that hasn't
seen fighting,
but exactly.
I want to make it exciting for him.
I want.
And I'm talking you through how I'm
looking at it.
I'm looking at his path.
So I'm like,
this guy's got this path.
He's got to secure.
That arm has got to get his hand
connected.
You know?
And when you bring people in like that,
you,
you're,
you're with,
you're in is my mind.
I mean that's what's going on in my head
when I'm watching the fight.
Go Watch them out.
Needed a stomach.
There's something always got full mouth.
Oh,
I see it coming.
You know,
I see like these paths and I want to
just guide people through the path.
It's,
it's,
it's the most non job job I've ever had.
Oh,
I can see it.
I can look like you're just floating
through it.
I love it.
The thing I realized about myself was
that I loved violence,
but it has to be real.
Like I don't like violent movies.
Did it,
did it.
Did to see Joey peshy a 60 year old guy
beating up some 20 year old kid.
What the fuck?
No fucking bullshit.
I was there that night when you invited
me to the pump.
These guys really getting fucking
whacked and,
and you know,
you know,
when it really hits,
the reality is when you sit.
And like I told you,
I was sitting behind the guy's mother
and girlfriend when he got knocked out.
And the mother's like,
chew me,
you know,
like real fun.
I love the pounding they take.
Yeah.
It's odd that you remember the kid,
the Tasmanian devil is just ran up the
thing and did like flips over or do you
remember him talking about?
It was Kinda,
it maybe he was like maybe Mulatto or
maybe from an island or something.
He's kind of a light skin black kid and
he was phenomenal.
He was,
he was,
he was leaping in the air like eight
feet.
And I'm talking about jealousy.
I do.
I can't believe I don't have his name on
the top of.
Hold on.
Whoa.
But he was,
it was like they spread the camera up
when you were watching him.
He was a,
he was the one that knocked the guy out.
Yeah.
I have to.
I have to find out what his name is
right now because he's fucking
brilliant.
And he's an up and coming kid.
So just give me a.
So while we're waiting,
let's talk more about supplements.
Hey Don.
What was it like meeting Johnny Carson
was.
Do you have any stories of anything cool
that,
that happened and the thing about it is
that was like in 1986,
so that's when the tonight show is still
really big and it was not fun.
It was a,
it was an experience.
It was like a,
um,
an imprimatur of comedy.
It was an experience.
John John Shits,
sorry,
keep calling shiny shit.
Uh,
but Carson,
I wanted,
I looked in the hills and burbank and I
wonder to run away,
I wanted to run away and start a new
life like in the hills because I was so
fucking afraid of getting on that stage
when they.
Because Jim Mccauley,
the guide book that comes and talks to
you and then they pull it back in.
There it is.
John Dodson,
sorry,
what's his name?
John Dotson.
That was the kid.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
He's an athlete.
He,
he moves like a cartoon.
Flies through the air.
Yeah.
It's just super talented.
He was doing that flip.
He was like running up the walls.
Yeah.
He's incredible.
He's.
Yeah,
he does like cartoon is shit.
It's like so,
like,
so gifted.
You know,
he's just got like a,
almost like an acrobatic ability,
whatever you're saying,
you were terrified.
Just terrified to go on the stage.
Show is there,
the curtain go back and it's unreal that
you hear Johnny Carson laughing and Ed
Mcmahon a little and see I had done a
joke but that man and when,
when I saw him backstage,
he pulled me towards him.
I think I'll fucking head's going to
slide me right before I go on because he
and I actually,
I didn't know that he loved the joke,
but you remember the joke?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was like,
um,
you call them our,
what do I call?
I said I met Ed Mcmahon.
He's,
you know,
he's been in show business for 35 years,
but what,
um,
what do I go up to them and say,
Hi ed calling Mr and Mr d dot Mr Eddie
Mcmahon.
You big fat lucky town was kissing.
Johnny's asked for the list.
Thirty years you budweiser sucking out
slinging nothing.
What do you do?
I don't mean that in a way that was a
joke.
Right?
And you know,
not a nice joke,
but hopefully,
you know,
he took it in the spirit that he was a
big success and I was a new comic and
that's the way he took it,
you know.
That's awesome.
I watched Johnny Carson every single
day.
I never missed it.
And I was a kid and that was it.
There was no VCR is when I was a kid.
But I would sit there and watch it
everyday.
I think I remembered you from that.
When I first moved to La,
I met you at the comedy store and I was
like,
from Johnny Carson.
Sure,
for sure.
Saw Young Carson,
a bunch of guys on Carson that wouldn't
be in great comedians.
I saw Jenny on Carson for the first
time.
It was a great community.
It was a great comedian.
Did Ed smell like Daniel isn't even one
of the most underrated guys,
don't you think?
If you go back to the people wouldn't
know,
but they'd know they'd go,
yeah,
that guy.
But yeah,
as far as like,
uh.
Do you remember how good,
how strong his act was in the late
eighties,
the late eighties,
the eighties.
Like in the early nineties,
he would go,
he went to East side comedy club and
they said he did a,
he did three different shows in a row,
three complete different hours,
completely different from beginning to
end.
And he was mad at me for like 10,
15 years because when he started out he
only had 25 minutes,
like a lot of us and I had to cover for
him and me and this guy,
Mitch Walters,
we were in Florida and at this place
called the comic strip.
And he would,
he would,
we used to say we'd squirrel his money
in the daytime.
We would buy all the food for the place.
Then he buys chicks it not buy drinks
for chicks at night.
And so we started calling them squirrel
and you know,
it was just like normal ball Boston,
like very mild hazing.
But he took it real seriously and he was
hurt and he was,
he was mad for years ago.
But Richard,
we're just kidding.
But,
you know,
he was kind of,
I mean,
I didn't know that he was,
it was so psychotic that he was in that
kind of pain that he would shoot
himself.
But,
you know,
he,
I did see symptoms of incredible
insecurity and incredible holding onto
things,
you know.
Uh,
but I mean,
that's so common with like really good
comics,
isn't it?
There's so many good comments.
So just sell fucking nutty,
you know,
all of us are.
I mean,
I,
I straddled reality a lot.
I mean,
it wasn't for alcohol and Xanax.
I wouldn't go out of the house half the
time.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
You have a boy or a girl,
phobic feelings.
I don't want to get internally at the
oprah thing.
But when did that start happening?
Since I was a kid,
since I was really bandon than the
yellowstone national park,
I was abandoned in the Grand Canyon.
So I have a fear of widths.
Uh,
I dunno,
I mean,
how.
I don't want to get too heavy,
but yeah,
I've always had.
And you don't have any neurotic.
You were up in bay,
you weren't really abandoned.
No,
no,
that's just a joke.
It's not even a joke because the joke
would be funny.
That was kind of shocking stage.
I would.
I would start laughing because I thought
you were like underneath that tree and I
was thinking about little squirrels
coming up and kissing you and try to
web.
Yup.
I read this story recently about this
guy who got killed by a bear real
recently and they had a track down bed,
did it?
It's happened twice in the last year and
the in in yellowstone,
and it had to before,
since the
19 eighties.
It's pretty uncommon,
but this one unfortunately wasn't just a
kill.
They had eaten part of this dude.
So then you got to kill that bear.
That's a bear.
That's discovered that human beings are
a food source and delicious by the way.
And easy to remember eating sophie out.
Hello?
Did I lose you podcast fans?
Chrysler's not swan,
so it's the same thing.
Don't make you gay.
No,
the fuck are you talking about bear.
He's a bear.
Nevermind.
So the.
They had to track this,
pared down and kill it,
and they're all tagged anyway.
I don't think so.
No,
no,
no.
There's.
I think a lot of them are.
I don't think they've got them all.
I don't know how they deal with that.
You know,
it's kind of a weird thing.
This is this one wild area that people
venture into,
but there's this huge dog things that
will occasionally fucking eat you,
especially if they catch you with their
cubs when they're with their cubs.
They get,
they get crazy.
Well,
what were you telling me before about
the guy that beat up and killed all
those bulls?
What's crazy about one significant night
in your life?
Yeah.
He knows.
Somebody says,
I got a story.
You got a story.
I'll tell you this.
Yeah,
I want to say the exact right number,
but I think it was something like 11
dead wolves and he had shot a bunch of
them and then he had a apparently a run
out of bullets or as gun jammed and then
he beat a bunch of them to death with
his butt.
So they found him and like 11 dead
wolves and then eventually the wolves
got them the rest of the pack killed.
Oh,
they did get him.
Oh yeah.
He,
yeah,
he was a,
I believe I said a lot.
I said Alaska,
but it might've been wrong.
It might've been Canada.
How many wolves were in that pack?
I don't know,
man.
There could be 100 and another five or
six.
Sometimes they're like 30 or 50,
but there had been super pacs cited
recently in Russia that they're,
they're really getting scared of that
were in the hundreds.
And what's funny about that is they're
all starving to death.
There's no fucking food out there.
So they're sneaking into these,
uh,
industrial area or the farming areas and
she's fucking up their cattle.
Just going in there.
I mean,
we're talking about a hundred bowls just
coming in in a,
in a mass swoop.
Could you imagine if you're living,
you're,
you're some poor.
Fuck,
that's a sheep farmer in Siberia or
wherever the fuck you are and you're
just taking care of these sheep and it's
freezing cold out and hear him.
I
hear that stupid shit every day and then
one day you look out the window and
there's 400 fucking wolves,
400 of them.
Could you imagine 400 fucking walls,
that feeling of being trapped in your
house with 400 wolves out there and they
just start jacking his,
tear them apart right in front of you.
I told you I made a confession of Joe
this week that I didn't want
know.
I finally told them why they didn't come
over his house because I was afraid of
his pit bulls and you know,
I know that all I pictured was the bull
flying through the air and latching onto
my juggler and Joe's screaming.
He never did this before.
He really.
He's really a sweet dog.
They pray with people.
Pimples are great with people.
I remember.
I remember you have to worry about one.
They slid under the fence and was biting
that other dog know he,
he.
I had to have my fence welded.
I had to have a bar welded around the
perimeter of the fence because he
figured out that he could get his head
in and bend the bars just by sheer
force.
Yeah.
He had his.
Any animals that we either so crazy.
The kids that you have.
Imagine your little girl and then it
burned.
I spoken to her in the eye and the dog.
You know what I mean?
I agree with kids.
It's very dangerous,
especially if they don't grow up with
the kids.
If they're not a baby with the kids and
they get jealous is that they get
jealous and also they don't.
They don't think of it necessarily as a
human being.
It's small.
It's a different thing and they might
bite it,
you know,
and that,
that,
that is possible.
If it annoys them,
they might bite it in,
in,
in a way that they would never bite a
person,
but they might buy the cat.
You know what I mean?
They're,
they're dangerous at any dog is
dangerous.
It's not trained properly and especially
dogs with a high prey drive except,
but they're so fun to be around.
They're so friendly and loyal and
energetic and they're so happy to see
you and they're so smart.
They're so smart dogs,
but unfortunately all that intelligence
comes with a burden and the burden is
the way they are ultra dogs and the way
they became ultra dogs as they raised
them,
fighting each other and they killed all
the ones that weren't superior.
They really just kept a strong blood
lines,
you know,
so if you get a dog that's like a real
fighting dog,
those are some of the smartest dogs
you'll ever have.
Bryan county used to have this pit bull
and it was like a direct fighting dog.
We bought it from a dude who fought
dogs.
I was there with him.
We went and this dude,
they would gamble on dog fighting and
the guy was explaining to us that the
dogs don't die and he's like,
you don't let your dog get killed.
And he goes,
it's all about gambling and it's all
about breeding.
The pitfalls that it to them.
He had been doing this for generation
upon generation.
Apparently I bought some.
Michael Vick was saying that it was a
cultural thing.
Yeah.
I don't buy that.
Yield a lot of them by electrocuting
them,
man.
That's the dark side of it is that they,
they take these animals after they,
you know,
got to fuck each other up and then they
shoot.
One of them were killed.
One of them,
the one that quit,
they don't even want them to breed.
He got scared and turned away from the
other dog.
They don't even want them to breed.
They want them to just fight
mercilessly,
fight until somebody pulls them off.
It's just a fucked up thing to breed
into a dog.
It's a fucked up behavior trait to
breathe in.
There's this old frail lady in Burbank
and walks her pit bulls,
two of them every day and every time I
see it I'm like,
that's not cool.
You have at least be able
to like if something happened to take
care of it and that slap it with the
white glove and not every pit bull will
freak out.
Fuck other dogs up.
Some pit bulls are very well socialized
and well trained and you know,
they're exercised well so they're,
you know,
they get tired out and that's the
important thing with dogs.
Two dogs are just like people,
man,
you got throw the ball for the dog,
you know,
you gotta give the dog some space,
my dogs have a big yard to run around
and it's great.
They need that man.
Dogs need,
they need to be able to,
you know,
to just to blow off some steam.
Otherwise their tents,
you know,
a dog into the house all the time.
It doesn't get to get out of those dogs
will bark and jump up in the air.
They're fucking freaking out.
They're like,
Jesus Christ,
you keep me and locked them in a box all
day.
I'm a dog.
I'm supposed to be out running around,
you know?
So if you have two pitbulls,
man,
you better make sure that you put those
fuckers through a good little workout
routine.
I need to start bringing my dog here and
kind of dog just sits there and says,
ah,
have a dog who's in love with me.
He's gay and dog.
He actually,
when he sees me he goes,
oh,
you know,
like real.
Is that fucker good?
Good.
I loved this gut,
but I mean really like,
you know,
they'll do dog bits like that,
that my act.
But I mean,
it really is amazing how his reacts to
me.
Whatever it is.
Yet dogs are beautiful like that.
That's why people like having them as
pets or people talking about having like
a pet bird or something.
Like what are you talking about?
Stupid snake.
Oh,
get up by the paradigm.
I went through a phase for awhile.
I just saw.
I met a really cool pair and I was like,
that's so beautiful.
I want that in my bedroom.
And look,
I had a pair of ones climbed up on my,
uh,
my shoulder and I had a baseball hat on
and he bit the little top button off the
top of the handles.
Yeah,
that'd be fun to have around.
No,
I didn't buy one had claws.
I don't trust anything with claws.
Get the fuck out of here.
You know?
Come on.
God.
What kind of creepy thing you got in
your life that's a falcon on your of
this new one that they just discovered.
They just did the newest fossil that
they've uncovered of the biggest bird
that ever lived.
It was 30 feet long and weighed 3000
pounds.
It's giant fucking predatory.
The monster is grey goose chases.
Birds Dragon,
right?
Oh yeah.
If it's 30 feet long,
that's what you're asking.
That's not a burden.
That's amazing.
Well,
it's covered in feathers.
It's really fucked.
Or dragons,
aren't they scale.
Maybe they were scales and we just suck
at feather detections.
You know what I saw last night?
Speaking of dragons,
I saw the wrath of the titans.
Is that what it's called?
The one is a last one.
Oh my God.
Is it bad?
It's so bad.
It's so.
It's so bad that you were almost like,
did you even this out
or did you just.
Did you laugh at it?
Was that bad or was stunning?
It was stunning because it was for.
First of all,
the CGI is fucking incredible.
Okay.
As a CGI,
seems like they just put the entire
budget on making it look bad ass.
I don't usually even like three d
movies,
but this is a really well done.
Three d movie,
like a kids movie.
No.
Well,
yeah,
sorta.
I mean it's like pg or something like
that.
Maybe it's PG.
13 for violence,
sword fighting and shit.
A lot of the monsters were incredible.
They had this fucking dragon thing.
There's two headed dragon.
Holy Shit.
Was it cool?
Like really fucking cool.
There's good things about this movie.
The.
Yeah,
the monsters.
It's like a CGI CGI videos,
monster porn film where the talking in
between the fucking is way too long.
You ever see like,
come on.
Especially like if you're in a hotel
room and you can't fast forward it,
you got to just like sit and watch these
dummies acts out this distinct.
She likes you,
kiss her,
kiss her.
I don't want to get rejected man.
After Cindy left me,
I just,
I just don't have that kind of
confidence anymore.
Well,
yeah.
I don't know.
What could I do that give you more
confidence?
I liked the,
uh,
the lesbian,
they make me laugh.
And Lesbian Porn.
Yeah.
Especially like the mother daughter was
sick.
Is that just.
Yeah,
that's fucked up.
Mother Daughter Exchange Club where
these mothers take their daughters over
to switch those.
The both go with older women,
but the daughter ever seen that one?
No,
neither did I,
but I heard about it.
I wouldn't ever watch something like
that sick.
I have it on my phone.
Yeah.
I've saw one of them where a mother and
daughter were sharing it.
Derek,
the mother was stuffed in the daughter's
mouth and it was the daughter's mouth
girl looked like her as the sun's Dick.
No,
I bet there's a video like that must be
for real.
There's one for everything.
We've thought it up.
Somebody is already like,
come on.
My glasses.
Fetishes know that this foot fetishes
were dudes only want to come on girls,
feet,
fetishes,
wherever the people put fingers and
guy's penis holes.
Guys like.
And guys like.
Then there's the other way around where
you guys fuck girls,
pee holes and like how is it possible to
get a dig inside?
There's videos.
Look at it,
it's fucked up.
It's actually,
people liked it,
but I look at them every day.
I saw a pop or rock thing happened last
night.
This,
this is the craziest thing ever.
Okay.
Uh,
we're at the Improv and for comedy juice
and there's a big gang of comics outside
of the Improv,
you know,
and just hanging out smoking cigarettes
and shit.
And across the street there's like this
Mexican Tequila Bar and uh,
this some,
yeah,
some celebrity came was coming out and
the valet put their car there and it was
like Lindsay Lohan style,
Papa razzies everywhere,
like fucking flashbulbs and fucking
jumping on top of their car,
like around the cars,
you know,
like,
like surrounding
them,
like Zombie style.
And so they're in the car and they're
taking photos of photos.
So all the comics were just screaming
stupid shit across the street.
Nothing like really bad ones.
It's like don't Princess Diana her and,
and uh,
like is that Lindsay Lohan and just
stupid shit.
And so the car takes out and it's some
girl from I think a fast and furious to.
I can't remember her name.
Maybe even Mendez Menendez or something
like that.
I don't.
I don't even know if that was her,
but I.
it's just not your first language.
So she drove by and she's smiling at.
It's like,
like how you guys were funny while this
whole thing happened.
So it was cool because all the comics
like yeah,
mission accomplished and,
but then second they left all the Papa
razzies is big gang.
Just fucking slowly started walking into
traffic and cars honking the horn,
slamming on the brakes and they didn't
give a shit and they're just walking
across the street and then getting up
into all the comics.
Face doesn't go.
You got fucking problems.
And like,
like they were like,
yeah.
Then they were all about to like fucking
just start beating the shit out.
All these fat improv comic guys.
Aggressive pumper Raj.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
And then I pulled out my iphone and I
started recording it because that's what
I thought I would do.
But unfortunately the,
the facetime was facing me but I didn't
notice it.
So it's just my physical.
But then halfway through it I look over,
I'm like,
oh fuck.
And I turned it over and then I show
them all like walking away,
like gang style,
like walking through the street,
like a fucking gang fight.
Right.
It was fucking crazy.
So then,
uh,
once they all,
they all take off and selling,
one of the paparazzis came back on this
motorcycle going down the wrong way of
melrose.
It was like in and out of cars,
like scary.
It was scary as fuck slams on brakes
across street talks to the valets points
over to us and then fucking just takes
off and blows through like two red
lights.
And I was just like,
what the fuck are these pop razzing
expect getting them.
It was scary,
dude.
It was like,
I was just sitting there going,
what the,
like you gotta think who these people
are.
People their stockers or professional
stalkers.
They're fun.
They're terrifying.
Those guys are terrified.
They're also,
I think they have to fortify because a
lot of people like lash out at them.
Yeah.
You know.
Well now I don't,
like you mentioned being in Lindsay
Lohan.
No,
or somebody like that and just have that
shit happened to them.
That's scary about it is a better at
that.
What would you do?
That's why I think the aids blood thing
I was talking about,
but you had aids blend just started like
going in and around.
Really.
Honestly,
I don't think it should be legal to have
a gang of people just standing out there
with a camera and photographing someone
like that.
Freaking people out and especially when
they're walking into traffic like that,
like that should be something you should
be able to get in trouble for.
It seems like,
you know,
if you want to go bust pot shops,
pop shops are hurting anybody.
These guys are walking in traffic and
big giant groups from freaking out.
Some chick it less and here's the big
and less the real and less and less.
She set it all up and that's exactly
what I was thinking too because it was
like,
why is this one e five people and none
of us knew who this girl is.
I think that's what they do.
Look,
everybody's got to grind out of.
I don't.
I don't want to hit a
guy trying to make a living if the west
wait and make a living as taking
pictures of Eva Mendez or whoever the
fuck it is,
as long as they're not really harassing
people and I don't think they offer for
the most part.
I think a lot of it.
There's a few that'll mean like clearly
when Brittany spears was going bonkers
and shaving her head and running around
and beat and cars with a umbrella.
Clearly they were just following her
there.
There was no agreements there.
They were like,
let's follow this crazy bitch all day.
She's about to do something.
Nobody,
you know,
this is.
This is easy pickins,
but I know for a fact that people set up
fake situations where they tell someone
a Po,
a publicists will set it up with the
Paparazzi,
so the proper.
It waits for them so they make it look
like it's a big deal.
You know,
like,
oh my God,
they're everywhere.
I go,
what am I going to do?
Meanwhile they're fucking asking for it.
They're setting it up.
Of course.
Yeah.
It's part of a part of the whole,
let's be famous thing.
It was scary though.
It to me that,
that if that was me that had that happen
to me,
like with all the.
Because those people trying to pull out
in their car and it was just like 20
people around the car.
They were like,
come on and get the fuck away from my
car.
You know,
there's just like touching your car and
shit and then that would dub and there's
so much flashes.
How are you even being able to see when
you're.
We're trying to pull out into traffic.
The flashes alone,
those people,
any flashbulbs going off,
all those people should be like tickets.
Like if there's like,
that's like saying that's like trying to
distract somebody.
Fuck texting flash bulbs in your fucking
face.
Well it's definitely just the
giant mass of people that you say or
blocking the traffic you shouldn't be
able to do.
Would you ever want Lindsay Lohan on a
podcast?
Why?
I think it'd be interesting to talk to
her.
I think she thought I liked the skanky
blonde look.
I mean,
she's got a beautiful,
a redhead again,
but then when she was blonde and it was
obviously a little girl,
she still to stay redhead,
she might be the hottest.
So I contention about a lot of
celebrities when Michael Jordan was at
his peak and I really believe that they,
they don't,
they find people annoying,
but if they weren't,
they weren't recognized.
They feel insecure during a moment.
Here.
Don't bother me right now you think,
but a lot of these guys,
some people,
they definitely,
it's,
it's like being recognized is a big part
of it for them.
It gives them a charge when they go
somewhere and they get recognized,
you know,
we had,
everlast with house of Payne who's on
the other day.
He's the exact opposite.
He likes to sneak in
favorite podcasts of all time by far my
favorite.
Thank God.
Damn good.
This is too old to try harder.
This could be okay.
I feel like we're real close now.
The reason why I liked it because he
played live acute acoustics.
Job Pretty much got her own concert.
It was fucking off the songs.
New Songs we had not heard before and
they were really good and he's a good
father.
I was having heart palpitations.
They can do what you can't do that
you love seemed so impossible,
you know,
because when people go stand up comedy
so hard and I'm thinking playing a 12
string guitar,
like this neurosurgeon friend of mine
people left with,
you know,
like we can't have a neurosurgeon for it
because we're like,
you know,
joke monkeys.
That's whatever.
I'm bad.
I'm,
no,
I just go ahead because I know what
you're gonna.
Say what he says I could never do.
You do.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean you always have neurosurgery.
I mean that's hilarious.
He said,
but he said,
I can never do what you do.
I said I didn't have released.
You can kid around a little.
You can kid around with your family.
Make people eat.
I can't do a little neurosurgery.
It's true though.
You can't pop in the dor a as this was
getting the head cracked open.
Well,
there's a lot of people that wish they
were funny.
It a lot of like really stayed.
A lot of people think they're funny,
some people think they're funny,
but there's a lot of people that wish
they were and just for whatever reason,
they can't figure out how to how to do
that.
What is that?
They take themselves too seriously.
I don't.
I think that's diluted a lot of times
that there was a guy,
he said,
you know,
I'd like to be a comedian.
He goes,
but I'm not funny.
I go,
well,
you know,
I'd like to be a fucking trapeze
artists,
but I'm not very acrobatic.
You know what I mean?
Like,
what if you're not funny?
How can you be a comedian when we know a
lot of comedians that aren't funny but
they're successful because they know
some of the tricks and they're good
looking or they're good at marketing
themselves,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a lot of that.
This is a lot of people that get to a
certain level and you're like,
wow,
they really got that far.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
What was that?
You know?
But they like piece together an act
based on what they think is relevant
right now.
There's certain key things you can
always say and get applauses,
especially like if you're doing like a
specific ethnic cultural thing,
say like you're doing like a Latino.
Oh brother,
boom.
You know me and they'll say a couple of
Spanish words and you get like a big
thing,
you know what I mean?
You see?
But then you kind of see it with the
talions.
I sit with blacks,
you know
what's up with that,
Melissa?
You know,
man.
And the white guy who has a really good
black.
That's really good.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
That's pretty good.
I thought it was a black guy in the room
with me for a second.
You close your eyes.
Go ahead.
What's up?
What's up with people who say what's up?
Holy Cow.
Yeah.
Don was the host of the,
one of the first TV shows was over onto
him and we did the thing in Montreal.
That was it,
um,
comedy from the danger zone or
something.
Right,
right.
That was fun.
Yeah.
I remember bringing you up.
That was fun.
Montreal.
That was one of the best festivals ever.
That's a.
That was a fun festival.
I love that city.
It's a great city.
Talk about fucking hot girls.
Oh Lord,
my goodness.
Even the ugly sister.
Beautiful.
There's a lot of pretty girls up there,
mark.
Goodness is.
It's amazing.
It was pretty one sheet myself.
Be Very Pretty.
Ooh,
what's amazing.
Is it right below that as monsters?
Fucking main monsters.
Really not weird monsters.
I know.
You know.
Not all monsters ladies.
Don't get mad.
I met some pretty girls and mean don't
get me wrong.
Look when I go home after living in
Hollywood and you see the staff at the
laugh factory and you haven't been there
while there are standards,
the could be like girls with the laugh
factory.
They're so beautiful,
right?
I don't know who's hiring them,
but it's,
it's either a woman who's not jealous of
other woman or a man because they're
beautiful and I go back to where I'm
from and not that I,
you know,
look at me and it's not like I'm so hot.
I'm Kinda cute and way,
but people look like,
like extras from the hunchback of Notre
Dame.
What I mean like they're shuffling
around and shit and you know,
you get used to this level of beauty.
It's out here.
It's weird level of beauty two.
It's like a really hard to maintain
level.
Oh yeah.
You know,
Katana,
the Japanese restaurant next to the
store.
We were in Jones one night,
me and my friend and he says,
man,
she's hot.
I go,
yeah,
she's really hot,
but she ain't Katana hot.
What?
I mean like there's all levels when
there that's like the international
beauties.
There's a black chick,
there's an American Indian,
there's an Indian Indian,
there's a white girl is ridiculously hot
Asian girl with a star Tattoo over
eyebrow or something and you're like,
Whoa,
my in a real movie.
If I ever dated another girl,
I'm,
I'm going to like olive garden,
ugly.
Like I'm not gonna hide.
I think it's just too much work.
I think I just need to be taken care of
for a while.
Like I did all these girls were.
I'm like having to like be a certain
person and I do a bunch of shit,
like a lot of maintenance involved with
dating,
you know,
like,
uh,
just try harder and harder.
What does that mean?
Like just tired of trying so hard that
if I ever break up with my girl or
whatever and then like if I think the
next girl my day is going to be a girl,
like a,
like in a wheelchair.
Do you have a girl now?
Huh?
Yeah,
sure.
You do a little here and there.
So it's complicated.
It's complicated.
So what I don't understand what you're
saying.
What do you,
what are you saying?
You just want to be taken care of.
You don't want to try.
Like,
you don't want to move so much.
I don't like.
I'm dating people way out of my league
and so I think I need to go back to the,
well,
what is wrong with what's going wrong
with the dating people out of your
league?
It's the disbelief while you're fucking
though,
what the Hell is wrong?
Person me to fuck you.
What is it?
Besides that?
It's a reality.
You let things slide more I guess.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Slide with shitty with you and you take
it because they're hot as fuck.
I'm not and I'm not talking about my
current situation at all.
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
I'm just saying in general,
well,
I've been thinking about it
a lot lately is someone has to
appreciate you as much as you appreciate
them.
If there's any sort of an imbalance like
that,
like if someone feels like they can shit
on you because you won't do anything
because they have the upper hand,
the relationship because you'll never
break up with that.
There's a lot of people that get in
those kinds of relationships and it's
fucking stupid.
That's a.
that's a shitty way to live your life.
It's a cowardly way to live your life
and that's why a lot of damaged girls
will date guys that are way under them
and they do it on purpose to make sure
that guy's not going anywhere.
So a lot of times they'll meet like some
other dude and fuck them on the side.
That's what happens.
I'm looking for a damaged girl.
I really am.
I had a need,
somebody flawed because at my age I
can't go out with women my age.
I'm not going to go,
come on grandma and flip over,
you know,
I'm attracted to girls in their twenties
now I'm a lot older obviously,
so it never stops and.
No,
but I mean what I'm saying is I need
somebody with issues recently with daddy
issues or flawed in some way are so
enamored by my tablet.
They don't look at me like the Mongolian
looked that I am.
You know what I mean?
I really got an annual thing going on.
I do look Gelica slapped my face,
God from eating,
drinking and I see you're actually
trying to watch your diet now mean you
had the Chorizo and eggs for one egg.
Whites.
Egg was like,
that's kind of counteract that.
Teresa did the same thing.
Take weights and sausage.
Jerry's Deli.
So delicious though.
It's hard.
You know,
let's have a cheat meal every now and
then.
That's a good place to do it.
It's not for me man.
So close to the comedy store.
It's open 24 hours a day,
three waffles,
best place on sunset as the standard.
If they still have the same kind of
food,
I don't like it anymore.
You know what they add to tip to it,
uh,
your,
your food.
And I just looked at it the other day
and I'm like,
wait,
how long have they been doing this?
They just kind of put the tip into your
total.
So you gave him a double tip and for a
good year.
Good,
good.
You did well.
Good job.
I just don't like people that do that.
Yeah.
Well they probably had to do it because
so many fucking drunks come out of that
bar.
Also people,
Europeans and Canadians.
And that is sort of an international
sort of makes sense that they know
everything about our culture and then
all of a sudden they don't know about
tipping.
Yeah,
they don't.
That's an alien to them.
It's a funny thing.
They know a lot of them knowing they use
it as an excuse.
Yeah.
But it's weird when you ever go to,
you've been to,
uh,
England and Irish many times you tip
over there and they look at you like,
what you had done a lot.
I had American,
you know,
remember ritual.
Yes.
He said to me,
I got tipped in Scotland.
He goes,
don't tip these people.
You're going to ruin it for all of us.
Japan.
You don't tip in Japan.
Oh No.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird how we do.
I.
Who else does it besides Americans to
the French tip?
No.
Right.
Ten percent.
Maybe 10 percent of fresh is different.
There's.
Well,
I mean there's a thing they're on there
for a tip and a lot of the credit card.
Well even Canadians are different
because Canadians don't tip is about
Americans because you know,
wages.
Nobody to much American told me that.
That was what she,
that was her nickname for black people
or Canadians because they didn't tip
just like an.
Yeah,
that's an interesting phenomena.
The black culture does not tip and I
know the black culture,
but it is a portion of generally,
of course,
all black.
I mean,
I've been out with Charles Barkley to be
a name dropper and he's ridiculous.
Ridiculously generous.
He's a.
he's a very.
God didn't gave me,
this kid was late with the food.
Do you ever hear this story?
I know he was late with the food.
It took them a long time.
Charles gave him a rolex.
Here he goes,
here.
Maybe this help you keep time.
Wow.
That's cool.
Yeah,
it is.
Unfortunately a stereotype though that
fits,
you know,
there's a,
there's a video online of this girl who
gets back from a restaurant and it's
like,
why?
I think it's calling,
why I got a tip and have you ever seen
it?
It's got millions of hits and people
were so in the fucking comments was a
race war though.
The goddamn comments were a race war and
she's basically,
she's just being an ignorant dumb ass
and you know,
just flaunting and on camera.
Like wow,
I got a tip like who says who says I got
a tip?
And someone came out and ran out and met
her in the parking lot and said,
hey,
you shouldn't be stiffing us.
And,
and have you ever seen him pull it up,
pull it up because you want to hear
about why I got a tip,
waitresses tents up on youtube or the
waitress was telling me how,
like a lot of times the black girls are
mean to them when they're in the
audience and my theory on that,
and tell me what you think is that black
women get stiffed a lot culturally and
invite a lot of black men because part
of a success in some eyes have some
black men,
is to have a white chick.
You know what I mean?
They're part of the culture until they
become a celebrity or something.
Then they got this toll Nordic blonde
with them on some of this and say why I
got tip?
Why?
Why the fuck I gotTa to know?
That's really why the fuck look,
look up whatever she's referring to.
That's the one that is.
Why the fuck I got a tip like I,
you know,
it's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate that any culture would
have an inclination towards being
stingy.
You know?
That's,
that's unfortunate.
I think the best thing that could ever
happen to people in the black community
that get,
get accused of this is for it to become
embarrassing.
Then I'm all for it to become ridiculous
before.
It's like,
you know,
like everybody should realize that the
only way to prosperity is through
generosity.
If you're not generous person,
you'd probably not going get anywhere
and that you really holding yourself
back by not being kind and not,
not,
you know,
not being generous to other people.
You know,
it's a,
it's a shitty a aspect of any culture.
But this one chick,
do you find it?
You see?
Those are all reasons.
Ari's why the fuck I gotta do a search
for why the fuck I got a tip jar.
You got to get rid of this kid doesn't
even have a goddamn laptop.
He's go this silly ipad thingy.
Thinks he's slick.
I might be just be not on.
I don't even need it anymore.
It's on man.
It might not be on youtube anymore.
Like she pulled it down.
See it's,
I think it's called.
Why the fuck?
Yeah,
and that those all reserves.
Do you think somebody pulled it down?
Will you?
People were so mad at her.
She probably did pull it down.
Anyway.
Whatever.
It's unfortunate.
And then,
you know,
I'll say this on the podcast and I'll
get a bunch of things on twitter to the
moon.
People angry at me.
You know,
a lot of black people chip in.
Will they actually do.
If everybody knows,
you're telling me that a lot of them
don't.
Yes.
A lot of them don't tell them that's our
experience from living in new clubs for
the last 20 years.
Ya know what I mean?
It's also true of the British and the
Canadians and you know,
Italians are generous.
I got to say being Italian,
they want to make sure people are
looking though.
I got A.
Yeah,
I got it.
I'm over here.
Yeah,
we'll wrestle for a fucking check.
You and I,
I'm in.
Hilarity is next week in Cleveland.
You never went through hilarious and
Cleveland.
I know.
What did I do?
I did the Improv in Cleveland.
You'd love hilarity?
Yeah.
Good place.
Beautiful.
Rarely get to Cleveland.
I've only been there once with Charlie
Murphy and Heffron were touring across.
Great Guy.
Yeah.
You would like Charlie Murphy too.
I never met Sharon.
I looked at me and him.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
he's got an interesting story.
That was the guy you want to have
fucking balls.
He got on the Chappelle show when he was
in his forties.
Okay.
He had no success up to that really,
you know,
a little bit here and there,
but really struggling.
Got to the Chappelle show and all of a
sudden started doing stand up and start
with headline and like within a couple
of months,
that's 45.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Nope.
It's a,
it's a,
a bike check.
That's.
Well,
maybe it doesn't exist anymore.
Maybe she pulled it down.
Doesn't matter.
Whatever.
Um,
yeah.
She said.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Well the point is,
it's unfortunate when people are
shitheads no.
And what was your theory about the black
girls?
They get shafted in life.
No,
I think sometimes they get bitter
because they find that a lot of the
black men become successful.
Think of something.
This is not a general generalization.
This is,
I mean,
I mean this is a generalization
obviously,
but sometimes like they,
they find getting a white woman is an
arm piece and a sign of success.
You know what I mean?
It's a weird thing in.
Or maybe they just liked the way it
looks or maybe they just want to fuck it
to the man.
Maybe just think of it.
It's like some white dude to suppress
them.
Daughter fantasy.
Going on pound in it.
Do you think that's it Brian?
He keep nodding.
I'm just trying to think of something.
Right?
How big your next girlfriend's going to
be a buck.
70 bucks.
We love him.
Going back to an average girl,
I got to get myself on average or less
than amber dating porn stars.
The the girl that I lost my virginity
when she added me on facebook today.
Funny.
Is Porn star the term when you figure
they could suck to Cox for the first
time?
Never Star.
Imagine the rest of show business that
easy.
I don't remember being called a comedy
star and I did the tonight show.
You know what I mean?
I had done hbo specials,
all this Shit.
They're homemade comedy.
Struggling a comedian comedy store.
Yeah.
That is interesting.
It's like we're so uncomfortable with
sex that when we throw the word porn
around,
we have to have some nice star Pornstar
rocket,
like a porn star,
you know?
Oh,
he's a rock star.
Do you still watch a lot of porn?
No,
I try not to talk about camming
nowadays.
What about,
you know,
but it's try not to.
But there was a worm that came out like
Trojan,
half a million freaked me the fuck out.
Last shouldn't get freaked out.
She turned your Java off son.
You know what helped me was blood
pressure medication.
Yeah.
Because with blood pressure medication
that lowers your libido.
So now I feel just like I'm like kind of
Irish,
healthy sexually but not like fucking
monkey who has the fuck everything and
all the time and telling and genetics.
I mean literally we both have those
wonky Sicilian.
Yeah.
We have that.
Like if you get done fucked and you go
home and jerk off thinking about what
you just did,
how much fucking sexy.
Like I remember like,
you know,
sophie turned into me going,
how much do you need?
You know,
can you just play with my ass while I'm
asleep?
And she said,
oh,
getting too comfortable with you.
Is it because of the Alfredo Chicken
Alfredo Alfredo sauce?
That's what the Italians are known for.
It's a,
it's caveman genetics is what it is.
It's very simple.
Was we look like trolls will short wide
people.
That's,
that's a psyllium look,
you know,
wide fat head people.
That one,
Chris.
Fuck a lot.
Remember Christie?
Kristy was a redhead.
Yes,
she was.
She had a great body.
Oh my God.
She did we go into the wayback machine
with diamond.
Get out of my way back when I got hard
on 95
back in the desert.
I just got silk sheets.
Have Your own silk sheets.
What's one of those things is like,
why have I ever or done this before?
It is amazing.
Why would you ever have regular sheets
that you're laying there?
It's like laying in this silky.
It's nice image.
I like to get out of my head.
I got to lie alone.
Naked.
You take your underwear off because
remember the blankets to have this piece
on the end,
over one leg.
Remember this,
the blankets that had the silky on the
end used to be like put it against your
teeth when you were a baby and like all
that stuff.
You mentioned a whole blanket out that
silky and you're was so amazing.
So it's only like $40 on Amazon.
I highly recommended just by some silk
sheets.
You'll,
you'll never buy regular sheets again.
I don't think we'll get you a brian.
Do you do it all naked?
I do it all the time.
Goes to buy sheets.
Can Imagine Joe going by and she had to
buy something for yourself to orgasm
just with your penis on the sheets?
Probably could.
Yeah.
I mean it's really soft.
So where they get these uh,
Amazon.
Amazon is satin sheets.
Fixture dom naked.
Oh,
arm's flopping back and forth like a
seal.
Oh,
you come from me.
I always love when they always say when
you come from,
you know what that means.
I'm getting tired with your and y'all
get off me fucking freak.
Crazy asshole.
Hope next week South Park's all about
this
gang and silk sheets.
You don't taste.
People were really listening hope so I
think that would be so cool.
It would be hilarious if.
Because the week before,
I think anybody who watches it,
if it would know,
no one knows what we're talking about.
Uh,
there was a.
we've talked about this bigfoot show and
then they talked about it on south park
and someone on a message board said,
oh,
someone from south park probably heard
you guys talking about.
I'm like,
but hold on,
but anybody who watches that bigfoot
show is going to get the same job,
but you're only missing half of it
though.
Well also in that episode,
supposedly I haven't seen this episode,
but supposedly there was a part where
it's like,
don't just hit your butthole is all day
or something like that.
Cartman says.
And then the week before I have this
whole thing at desk squad where I take a
take a piece of bread and I take the
ICAT bread where you,
I tell my fans to send me photos of them
taking a piece of bread,
taking a hole out of the middle of the
brand and then putting their cat head
through it and I've been doing it for
about a month or so.
And then after that,
that last week's episode is all about
like fucking cap reading and shit like
that.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't invent it,
but it was definitely a lot of people
like a really small niche of the
Internet,
you know?
It was just there on the Internet.
Oh No,
no,
I'm just saying that.
It's kind of funny that,
that,
that's something that I've been doing a
lot lately on twitter,
but I'm not clear though.
Are you accusing them of watching?
No,
no,
no.
Here's what I'm saying.
Last week when last week's episode,
it was really weird watching it because
for the last month that's what I've been
doing on twitter nonstop.
So it was kind of cool to see that.
And then this week I heard that they
were talking about big foot and itching
assholes and I'm like,
this is getting cool.
I hope everything that we talk about
becomes a cell phone.
They're going to do is an episode about
a retard radio host who can't get his
facts straight.
Cartman for something.
We didn't really do a garden,
but did you say cat breading?
Cap Reading?
It's.
It's so fun.
Are you talking about breeding breading
now?
You can take a crust of bread.
You make a hole in it and then put your
cat's head through it and you take a
photo.
He's a grown man.
Who isn't that strange?
It's just fun to know.
Don't tell them they don't make people
like him in Philly.
Do they know?
Where are you from?
Ohio?
Where a Columbus.
Hello?
Columbus.
I when it's still in my Italian,
like growing up.
I don't need a new one.
Uh,
Italian.
It was my dad's best friend and he lives
in a,
I think Pittsburgh.
And the only thing I would,
or only time I ever go to Pittsburgh
back and forth,
once a year we'd go and they have this
huge party where he can just,
some fights,
all his families.
It was like the coolest thing ever.
That's how I know Italians were my first
time was that they were just,
had these huge parties with hundreds of
family members once a year.
And we were invited to that all the
time.
It was so cool.
Uh,
my first introduction,
Italians,
the Italian American society,
comes to see me every year at Columbus
at the funny bone really.
And so they invite me to dinner that
day,
the day I come in,
which is Wednesday.
And it's always fun.
You know,
Dino,
who's most willing to show that you did
it?
You've done the funny bone.
Yes.
Anyways,
so I go to this thing and it's at the
Italian club and last long story short
of fight fucking breaks out at a club.
But the club members wasn't like a club,
like a club in the public.
They're having a vote for the president
gets up and starts talking.
It's one guy goes,
you know,
it escalated so quickly,
like,
like one of those the fuck you looking
at nothing who you calling?
Nothing.
Fuck,
you know,
that kind of like,
you know what I mean?
I'm like,
we're real close to it.
It was like,
you know what you were saying,
you were saying about how you've seen
things like your hell unflappable.
You are like,
you've seen things right next to you and
it doesn't even faze you like the
violence.
Oh yeah.
Let's see.
So many fights.
That's what happened here,
but it was such an unlikely place.
[inaudible].
It was like everybody's cheering each
other.
They're all either either Italian or
have to have some connection to Italy,
you know,
whatever.
And a real fight broke out and I
couldn't believe it.
And you know,
you want a piece of this.
I always thought that was one of the
more unfortunate aspects of our culture.
Italian Americans are very prone to
violence,
very rounded.
Fistfights,
Italians and Irish and Italians and
Irish.
Irish in you,
right?
Yeah.
I got the best of both worlds.
Three quarters as I am one quarter
Irish.
Yeah.
That's they're always like,
well fuck you,
look at it.
There's always a lot of that,
especially the east coast,
although scruffy immigrants raised kids
that carried a lot of those same
mentalities.
The east coast is definitely more
hostile.
Do people ever
asked you about the mob?
Like you know it because you're.
But,
you know,
they were asking,
I,
I get it all the time really well
because of where I'm from.
And like,
you know,
like I lived in a poor black
neighborhood in west Philadelphia.
We moved from an Italian neighbor,
mean like we were really connected to
the mob.
Yeah.
Were undercover,
you know,
it's why we're in this row home in a
black neighborhood.
But uh,
because we were the press whites,
you know,
which was a very interesting perspective
of life because people don't ever think
about what about the white kids that
were let back in a black neighborhood.
I was lucky because I played ball and
they were all my friends,
but you couldn't walk through there just
like a black kid couldn't walk through
the Italian neighborhood.
Is that fucked up?
Yeah,
it's fucked up.
When are we going to move past that?
When you know the people,
they're all,
you know,
you like him?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Of course.
It's like any other community.
It's all about deciding who's going to
be nice to,
Oh,
you know,
he decided these are the people we're
going to be nice to and you're not going
to be nice.
Those assholes over there now.
Well,
we were talking about how we were in
Kentucky.
We were in Louisville and Louisville was
playing Louisville.
And how did that go when they were
playing crazy?
They started a riot and cars,
cars on fire and shit.
But the crazy thing is it's Louisville
versus Kentucky.
It's like assholes.
It's ridiculous.
You were in the same,
same stack as a fucking civil war.
This is the most preposterous thing
ever.
Yeah.
Well what I liked the same thing with
Auburn and Alabama and they,
it took a tornado to blow through
Tuscaloosa for those people to get in
touch with each other.
You know,
the same people.
It's crazy.
They're so prone to like hate the
neighbor or eight to.
Oh,
the hatfields and mccoys.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I said a onstage about Michigan in
Columbus,
Ohio state's group balloon man.
Why are you even talking about.
Yeah,
I've had people from Columbus Shit on.
People from Cincinnati.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck Michigan.
I hate them.
I don't know.
Meanwhile,
we're all supposed to be Americans.
All preposterous,
all these stupid fucking little
leaguers.
Mother's hanging out.
Preposterous.
I said,
I can't help myself.
You must be a Michigan guy.
He has a very prodigious vocabulary.
It's preposterous.
Has been the word of the month.
Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
I've been blasting it out.
Every time it comes into my stupid head,
it gets into a groove where you can
start saying words that definitely.
Because I remember when we used to say
something else,
Joe was the first one I ever heard say
what ever bananas or whatever you was
the first one that made that inflection
and it's spread all over the valley.
What ever you did,
you were the first one.
Yeah.
You're the first one I ever heard.
Say it and then everybody started saying
it and then he didn't say it.
As much as I say,
I don't understand what you're saying,
why,
you know,
you'd be talking about like something
that would piss you off and you know
what ever,
you know,
it's like the instead of saying whatever
you made that beat what ever and then I
didn't know I did that.
I really have no idea.
I get Joe,
I know you so much.
You know me very well.
My friends,
we've known each other a long time.
Tell me more.
We'd known each other since the
nineties.
We met back in the day when I was living
in New York.
I'm really bad at it.
Caroline's or at um,
um,
Amsterdam.
Billiards wants to.
We just ran into each other.
Tom and railroad can shoot a hell of a
game of pool.
Tell you that.
I'm going to start saying that.
Yeah.
That's what ever the pause that makes it
so unique and that caused the middle of
whatever.
That's where all the brilliance lies are
used to crack me up when people go to me
a like,
whatever.
Like you're going to take credit for
that.
And then you were the first one I heard,
but like people would say to me,
does it bother you that the sopranos do
Bada Boom,
Bada Bang?
I go,
no.
They go,
well you did it before them.
I go,
well,
because I was around before the show
started.
I didn't make up acting Italian.
Yeah,
I didn't make them forget about it.
You know why I was the first one that
should forget about it.
I had the nastiest thing happened to me
last night,
dropped my iphone in my beer and hold it
out real fast.
And then I just did the first thing.
I thought of it like I'll suck all the
beer out of the like sucking the holes
like as hard as I thought it was.
Shit was coming in my mouth.
But then like something like a slime
thing.
Flew mouth.
I'm like,
was that earwax or what the fuck was
that?
So I don't know if it was a orange
hefeweizen or if it was a battery to
have advisors.
Dude,
stop it.
It was a piece of orange.
Yeah.
But I was like,
like your beer.
And had a simple orange,
I'm your,
I'm going to be your Colombel and chill.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with him?
If there's anything wrong with them.
I've been working with his fucking ass
off for a decade.
He doesn't use anything wrong with him.
He thinks it's me.
He was like,
you know,
you just,
you're just tense from the east coast.
You crazy with all that karate.
She.
The interesting thing is the word
retarded convenience issues,
but there is something we'll do respect
to something retarded about you.
Look,
even that basement looked at.
He has kids my age difference.
Well I think so.
Everybody or a 37 year olds are rocking
it.
Like,
yeah,
I'm 37 and I rock it like a 22 year old,
which is different.
But what do you rock?
I'm rocking a Nintendo shirt right now.
Do you think.
I wonder if he's a Manchild.
You know what?
I imagine a lot of them work in the
computer game industry.
A lot of Manchild in the comic book
world.
You didn't know what your target market
is.
You get this Gig.
I mean a bullet.
People.
Joe knows what the fuck you doing over
there.
One's and zero's talking.
By the way,
I'm going to start talking like dropping
a one or a zero in normal conversation
just to put code into actually
communication.
Know what you're saying.
That what if you like to have the one
zero listens for a nuclear bomb when at
the end of the time,
you know when someone deciphers all your
fucking sentences for the month to
figure out a nuclear bomb.
Seven.
It's not seven dummy to one or zero.
You can't say seven out sloppy code.
The new shit.
Yeah.
This is what I do with them.
Don.
I'm sorry.
Oh No,
no,
you're good.
I think I could do better,
I think.
What do you think I should do with them?
I would cut his hours down.
Cut his so that he,
when he comes in,
he's more focused.
That's casting.
You do understand?
We smoke a shitload of weed before he
drove Rogan.
Wait,
so you get to see it.
The medical.
Uh,
I think for that show that's what's
important.
We both do what?
What's your,
what do you have to say that your,
your element is today?
How do you get medical look at
entertainment?
What's right with them?
I'm not even.
What's fine?
What's your anxiety?
It's good.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
The whole world.
Does that help?
Uh,
no,
no.
It doesn't help me.
I don't have anxiety.
Um,
I do have um,
uh,
definitely helps me go to sleep.
It makes food taste better.
I think the light's just playing a,
it helps,
uh,
if you've got injuries via Achy,
makes you feel a little bit better.
Relaxes you find it relaxes my muscles,
you know,
like Xanax,
they all like the.
We don't really know.
I don't like smoke.
Really.
You can eat it,
you know,
you,
you can eat,
need to attack what you said.
You haven't smoked weed,
those sense,
uh,
for a very long time.
And if you take so much xanax you might
just take a hit once just to see if it
does anything for you and get that new
stuff because this is a cheaper
alternative that will probably drink a
lot though.
I'm doing good.
I drank a lot.
He said it was like my vitamin you drink
everyday.
Do you like Ed Mcmahon style?
I do and I'm hung over every day,
which is really a testament to my comedy
because it's great.
That's a great thing about being a
comedian.
You can actually function as an um,
I'm way more joe then when we hung out a
lot.
I'm way more alcoholic then I think
because I graduated to a hard hard
liquor.
Oh yeah,
because of a girl.
I don't know where to go from here.
No,
because,
uh,
my girl,
my sister died a couple of other things.
So.
But I find that to be a really fun
habit.
You know,
I don't like the hangover,
but I time it,
I go,
well,
if I go to sleep,
pick a hamper,
xanax and six hours I'll be all right.
Right now I'm a little dizzy from the
combination of the tranquilizer and the
alcohol,
but I do feel better.
Are you supposed to take those two
together?
No.
How bad is it for you?
It's pretty cool.
It can stop your heart.
Yeah.
You can tell.
You're like,
well,
it's worth it.
No,
that's why I keep the time in between
them.
It like six to eight hours.
I made that up.
I totally made it up.
That's what I'm thinking.
That's what in the alcohol metabolize
and about that much.
If I'm drunk I don't take anything.
If I feel drunk.
No,
I wait until I feel.
But if you take the Xanax and you're
under the effects of it,
sometimes they'll have a couple drinks.
No,
no,
not usually.
I mean not.
So it's one of the plane,
maybe A.
Yeah,
it's one of the other hoping there's a
doctor on board.
Yeah.
Um,
you shouldn't do that.
You should switch to.
We'd get off my back.
We didn't even know me.
Man.
What is the main reason why you're doing
this?
What is the main reason for Xanax?
Xanax for anxiety,
anxiety,
know,
just like panic attacks.
When did these start?
When I,
uh,
when I was four for real.
This is a lesbian and raped one of my
entire family.
They passed me around the room.
They plugged me like a joint fleshlight
joy.
It just started pumping,
uh,
the eggs I always had.
Anxiety I was at,
I want a psychiatrist when I was in
seventh grade.
Really?
I was thinking,
well,
that's why I'm here to rebuild myself
and I'll be at hilarity next week and
you could see me a captain.
Brian's the following two weeks at a
time.
I went to a psychiatrist.
My mother sent me a psychiatrist and
what was it?
Four?
I was in love with him.
No,
I'm kidding.
I wish for,
you know,
pat anxiety,
panic attacks and wow.
I have all the same things.
I went to the hospital about a year and
a half ago.
I had to pull over and call nine,
one one on myself because I have an
anxiety attack.
Really cost me a lot.
I hope you know.
I was kidding.
And he was high as fuck.
Yeah.
You've actually started.
Something's already started.
It's already starting to hit me here.
Yeah.
Well you were high as fuck when you
pulled over.
I wasn't.
I just didn't eat all day.
You hallucinate A.
Yeah,
I was.
I was starting to see like trails and
stuff.
I felt like I was having a heart attack
the whole time.
I was like typical symptoms like and I
was like holding my neck and I could
feel my heartbeat,
but the thing that I didn't like the
ambulance and they were like,
yeah,
there's something wrong,
and I'm like,
oh,
now looking back,
I'm like,
well,
how don't know.
You might've had a heart attack mean,
didn't know you were having a panic.
I love these people that think they have
heart attacks.
They don't have chest pains,
don't even know what a fucking heart
attack is going to have.
Chest pains.
They have a heart attack.
I get that.
You would think so?
I would.
I'm pretty sure I'm was a smoker.
I get those too.
Sometimes.
You know,
he's a smoker toe.
Oh,
you smoke cigarettes.
A lot.
Kids will workout.
Oh No.
I'm like,
I'm pretty much like you.
I didn't know I work out though.
Yeah,
I'll work.
I work at dawn massage.
You know what that is?
It's very low impact.
You can actually eat while you're doing
it.
It's a form of.
I watched myself on a video just
exercise and I exercise that I,
I consider masturbation working out.
Is this a bit.
No bit.
I think you might want to throw that one
out and it's never been in.
What'd you say about working out?
What if you fuck pillars?
That's like working out.
So that's kind of any movement you do
more two minutes to your life on this
planet.
Is that true?
Especially for him?
Yeah,
sure.
It's one step on a grave.
One by appeal.
Dead Man.
Dead Man walking.
I get.
I'm not taken care of this vehicle now
he's just riding it and stuff and
cheetos and do it a little shit.
Beer and the cigarettes are.
The real issue was fucking unbelievably
bad for you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they are really bad.
You never get that right?
Should I go to sixth grade?
What did you do it for?
No,
I used to get.
My grandfather would get samples and I
would smoke cigarette one after another
in the fucking that we so dizzy.
It was like,
yeah,
I thought,
you know,
you get high by smoking just like only
after another.
He.
I did,
but it's not a fun high.
You're dizzy or lightheaded,
you know,
roll up.
I never threw up,
but it's nauseating.
I threw up from chewing tobacco once,
so gross the baseball player spit that
shit.
But it's on a rug.
Yeah,
the astronaut.
It's a rug.
It's not like grass where it gets
absorbed into the ground.
Right.
What is that?
Are they allowed to spit it on the
astroturf?
They do.
You see them?
Oh yeah.
Fucking nasty.
Remember that scene from the naked gun
or something where the world starts
spitting and.
Yeah,
they're just hilarious.
Fucking figured out how to do that.
Isn't it funny that that's legal?
Chewing tobacco,
but cocoa leaves our legal thing,
which is probably better for you.
Matter of fact,
it's definitely better for you.
I don't think people were eating chewing
cocoa leaves and getting cancer.
Have you ever see these new cancer
commercials in?
Oh my God.
Scared the fuck out of here.
Have you seen that one,
Brian?
They're pretty bad.
They're all are.
They all suck.
Especially like when they have holes in
their throats and that doesn't make you
want to quit smoking.
Guys looking at a windows maybe.
How long have you been smoking?
Since I was 15.
But the idea of starting now,
after all we've seen that's really crazy
drinking every day like,
I don't know,
alcohol is bad for you,
but the idea of like figuring out.
I think I'll start this.
I think I'll start this habit that I
don't have yet.
Just,
you know what,
what made you start?
Because you're saying you were way more
of an alcoholic now than you were.
It's a progressive disease,
you know.
That's the fun thing about it.
Did you get better at it?
Do you ever decide to do anything about
it?
Do you ever decide to slow down,
take whatever.
I'm hung over.
I quit until that night.
Then we had a funny thing.
I was on a tour bus,
remember when I was roping for sure.
Yeah.
We're funny thing that I created this
waitress at the laugh factory about the
other night.
Me and my friend Ali,
we never slept on the bus and were
drinking all night and we go,
we got to quit drinking a.
okay,
alright,
this is it.
It's stupid.
It's fucking killing,
killing our bodies.
And so in about an hour we're sobering
up and we go,
you know,
men drink it for a while and it's night
and scraping sober.
What do you say?
We celebrate our sobriety with the
drink.
So that was,
you know,
that this girl the other night a,
the factor.
We did something like,
she goes,
I'm not drinking that.
I said me neither.
All right,
well we'll have one as a reward for not
drinking.
You don't drink.
I drink.
I don't drink a lot.
I can take a shot man.
I can do shots.
Yeah,
I like to try to keep it as balanced as
possible.
You could get addicted to just getting
fucked up all the time and going
onstage,
onstage stage.
Fucked up anything.
I really lose it.
Quickness.
Yeah.
How many times he got upset onstage.
Fucked up accidentally though.
Maybe 10,
maybe.
Maybe 20.
50.
I hit,
you know when you know what's bad is
getting drunk.
If you're going to do an hour because
you got to pee,
you know,
you've got to really watch that.
That's true.
But I have A.
I'm not better as a drunk because I'm
not nervous doing standup.
So alcohol does me no good.
It just dulls me and it and it slows the
quickness down the reaction a little
bit,
you know,
supposed to timing on.
I mean I'm,
I'm much better on coffee than I am one
booze.
Yeah.
Because I don't have any fear of the
stage,
you know,
fear of.
I'm going to get you some of this
alphabet and stuff for real.
Take it before you go on stage telling
an hour before.
What is it?
The stuff we're selling it on,
it's all.
Yeah,
I got bottles of it,
something the other day I was really,
it started doing where I'll order it
like a vodka and diet coke and then I'll
tell the guy like everyday,
every three of them make them just diet
cokes and so I don't even know when I'm
doing it or not.
And I felt drunk at the end of the night
and I was like,
how many have I had it?
He was like,
you've had any auto and you've been here
for six hours,
so you're from.
So you couldn't have been yourself like
it was psychosomatic,
but it wasn't even like I was like,
am I drunk?
I don't even know if I'm drunk or not.
Like I was confused.
Is he retarded?
Tell me this is the first time you're
hanging out with them.
You don't know if you're drinking
alcohol at any.
Are you liking my journey?
I understand.
You know what he's like as if this is a
contradiction in terms.
He's a really bright retort.
No,
that's what I mean.
I don't know how else to put it.
Like this is exactly how my facebook.
That should be your new thing on your
message board.
Happiness of like a retarded kid,
you know,
the joy that they have with a smile.
He's pretty happy.
I'm pretty happy.
Go hang out with more.
Yeah.
Always hanging out with all this porn
star friends.
You really fucking porn stores truck.
Yeah.
The,
your scheme that they've been there or
they're not the girl.
Girl,
girl,
porn stars.
The girl girl.
There you go.
The only as.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You don't really have to do that from
Regina.
And I know it looks like you would get a
kick out of that.
Yeah.
It's a weird world.
It's uncomfortable getting to know that
world that with the normal to them too,
which is very strange.
Well,
it's,
it's so stereotypical.
That's the weird.
The weird thing about that world is,
you know,
a lot of them are very nice and you get
to meet them and you're like,
wow,
this is just some nice girl who just
somehow or another she found herself in
some situation where she has this almost
insatiable desire for sexual attention.
And lot of that is because they were
molested.
And then when you find that out,
it's a buzz kill.
Then you start feeling bad.
That humanized.
Humanize them.
You're gonna lose all your fantasy.
You lose your boner for sure.
When you,
um,
when you talked to some of them,
some of them say that nothing's ever
happened to him.
And I believe in,
I think there's,
it's possible that they could need
attention for other reasons.
Yeah,
a more.
I don't know,
maybe they just rationalize it.
I don't know.
You know,
or maybe that's just their reality.
And they don't have a problem with it.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with it.
I'm saying when you delve into that
world,
it's gotta be something wrong.
Well,
a lot of times there is strippers.
Dean,
I never met who was really working their
way through law school.
Very rare.
Some of them do like a Mike Young joke.
Yeah.
A bunch of genius trippers.
I never heard that.
Yeah,
I saw him last night.
Same jokes and no I didn't watch.
Sorry.
I just talk to them.
But how would you ever like him at Ice
House?
Would that be okay?
Sure.
Cool.
Why'd you bring that up in the air?
And I don't know if joe said No.
Yeah,
this fucking guy.
Well we've talked about Mike Young so
many times on podcast,
but we've never had him on anything.
He got his ass kicked one time.
Remember?
That was brutal.
He's got an interesting story about
that.
Yeah,
I mean I wouldn't want things going.
Is that him?
I don't know.
It's not.
My phone is so not my phone at your
phone or your phone,
Bro.
I don't even know where my phone is.
That's because it's fucking ran.
You crazy bitch.
He just had.
He was sucking on it.
Yeah,
I remember the whole thing.
You.
It wasn't stuffed it under your ass to
work with them on a regular basis.
Tom,
do you do stand up?
Yes.
On the road with Jodi.
Is She?
I know you told me you don't.
You don't believe he does stand up a
well.
You find that shocking.
I find it a little clump.
Uncomfortable to talk about what?
What's black and on top of the stairway.
Well,
Christopher Reeves after a fire.
That was really good like five years
ago.
That's good to hear.
Good Krista.
Good.
Chris Christopher.
Now you wonder why you get hate mail.
You wonder why people abandon a couple
of people from talking shit about Joe on
the message board.
Oh,
by the way,
did you watch the podcast?
Your message board now has a podcast
that Jay mute jason and Voodoo and
Johnny rotten did do it themselves or
might fly up one day and go to.
We should do a gig up.
That'd be awesome Gig in Seattle.
And then do the broadcast.
Definitely.
You know,
it's a joke that I love.
Tell him,
what did you think of this?
Maybe you heard it.
It goes to psychiatrists.
Psychiatrists is.
What's the problem?
He goes,
I don't know,
Doug.
I just can't seem to keep any friends.
You Fat.
Fuck what?
You said you went to a psychiatrist when
you're 17,
if you've been in 13.
Oh 13.
Really?
Twelve,
13 years.
Wow.
Have you been as an adult?
I'm not a psychiatrist.
Psychologist.
That's the kind of.
Don't prescribe drugs.
Right?
Want to talk about that?
No.
Telling you like pot.
The xanax stuff.
What does it do?
It kills.
Anxiety.
Makes you relax.
That what it does.
Yeah,
it's great.
It makes you feel like you're.
You're a normal person.
What I've heard though is that if you
take it and then you get off at the
anxiety actually increases.
Well,
I wouldn't get off it.
So it's a daily thing.
Every day.
I had just heard from someone,
we were just talking about this and he
goes,
I couldn't fucking imagine taking xanax
every day.
He just said this to me because it makes
you sleepy.
I don't know.
I don't know what it does.
Is it do it?
Do you want to try one?
No.
Well,
why don't we.
When we get in the car,
I'll give you one.
I don't think it's for me.
I've actually tried it now.
I'm glad that you do part.
I'm glad I.
I'm telling you like I was telling you
before,
you seem so much more at peace with
yourself.
I had a bunch of come down a lot.
I think it definitely helped.
I had a bunch of life experiences,
a bunch of,
a bunch of psychedelic experiences to a
bunch of.
I'd be so afraid to do that shit.
Yeah.
Why?
But because I'm a pushy registered,
I've learned it.
Uh,
the psychedelics changed me a lot for
sure.
You know,
it's just,
it's hard to gain perspective.
I'm not sure I've done them.
I'm sure several times.
It's not about bath salts as you don't
even say that.
Brian fucking.
Somebody might hear that and it's some
new fucked up drug they're selling.
It's like a cousin to crystal meth and
they can sell it,
and what's even worse is that fake we'd
that we'd.
I've been reading all the shit lately
about that fake weed,
that synthetic,
synthetic weed,
how bad it is for you.
That was good about the part that you
get is that you're getting it from an
illegal place,
which means hopefully it's not tainted
in anything.
I don't know why anybody would go to a
really shady neighborhood and buy shit
on for a drug dealer who may never see
them again.
Why would you trust that guy?
Let me cut it.
You gotta do what you gotta do it the
cheapest price you gotta do what you got
to pay when you're in a dance.
One of them.
It's one of those sayings that he can't
argue with you gotta do what you gotTa
do.
It is what it is,
like whatever it is,
what it is,
what else could it be and what it is.
What else could it be?
It can be a.
You could be looking at it in a
distorted way because they're saying
what it is.
What it is,
is you might be looking at it and some
sort of a fucked up way to justify your
position.
I never expected an answer to that
question.
That was a rhetorical question.
I appreciate the.
I'm one of those guys.
I don't let them off float out there.
If you walk around a rhetorical one,
that needs to be addressed in a very
literal sense already.
I was laughing about something last
night about you was telling eleanor,
but uh,
I would,
um,
you know,
he's so good at pool Joe that I,
it's really tough to beat and even the
nine boy,
what you can,
can involve a lot of luck.
And uh,
I would start talking about Carlos just
10 years ago.
Say I just to aggravate him and it's
fucking stick with prop,
you know,
like he would get aggravated just
looking for any kind of edge at the
comedy store.
The other day I was there,
somebody tore down the car and Cs
pitcher and threatened the trash and I
went out.
I did it.
I was like,
fucking asshole is someone trying to
impress you.
Probably somebody wants you to be a
boyfriend.
Did you do stand up at the comedy store?
I'm only allowed on friends and family.
You know,
like,
like if there's a host site now,
they'll let me.
Do you do the belly room?
No room or no army fight.
It's like a three to five minutes.
It's a great club.
What a great old time club.
Dominic,
what's your favorite club in the
country?
Probably that one in Columbus.
As far as a,
a neutral club,
I mean,
you know.
Yeah,
I mean I love the wildwood.
When I do the wall would gig.
Uh,
it's really special to me because I'm
from philly and while it's like the
suburb of Philly that,
you know,
do you do helium?
Yeah.
Great Club.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's another all time classic.
I'm doing.
Do you ever do captain Brian's?
Did I ask you that?
No ship.
It's in Marco Island.
So it's beautiful.
It's a great gig.
It looks like a b room,
but they pay like a and a room and it's
just fun.
I mean,
being on,
you know,
that kind of environment that Columbus,
Ohio,
by the way,
funny button.
That's my home club.
Started up strips,
a great guy.
I also like Tampa,
uh,
and uh,
the Hollywood improv.
How many years?
It wasn't a weeks a.
are you on the road a year?
I don't know,
Joe.
It's opened up from doing tv or not.
You know,
like when I was doing that judge show,
uh,
it was less,
I would say at least half the time.
What was that Judge Show?
It was like,
it was called Supreme Court,
a comedy.
It's actually coming back.
It was on direct TV and it was fun,
you know,
it was,
I'd love
you to do it because I'm the judge and
it's real small claims cases and they
people sign a contract that says they
can't sue again in a real small claims
court that I make the final decision.
And I just told them,
I says,
you know,
I don't really know much about the law.
I said,
I'm not fair.
If it's a hot chick,
you're going to win something.
And you know,
that's the way life is.
You know,
I did some exactly like that long time
ago.
They tried Merv Griffin tried to do it.
It's called Rogan's law St.
pilot for it before I ever did fear
factor.
Yeah.
Didn't.
They didn't do it though.
They never.
Would.
You have comedians is the lawyers?
Yeah.
No,
not as lawyers.
There's no comedians as a lawyers,
but there's a wish I could remember
their names.
She had comics.
I see him around the Improv.
I'm sorry,
I'm blanking on his name.
He was the bailiff and there was another
call.
We had hot chicks is the bail and.
Oh really?
And that's why your show worked in mind.
Didn't even go past.
We did three.
We did three years in Moonee.
Do something like that too when he was
on my show a lot.
Yeah.
And He,
I gotta say he really gave good energy.
I really did.
He was a pro.
He really will.
He really went out 100 percent,
you know,
it was fun.
Know who was fucking hilarious.
Was a little sandy,
Andy kindler killers.
He had me crying,
laughing.
Let's little nebbishy Jewish guy.
He's walking around with these almost
like woody Allen look,
and he was funny and it's interesting to
see because you could tell which
comedians have improv chops and which
guys are only funny behind the racked
right way.
Sure.
And I'll tell you who was really
prepared to the point where it was like
a lawyer was love.
It's really.
Oh,
he went up against Kevin Pollak.
Poor Kevin pollock.
He was doing Adam Arkin impressions at
Adam.
Mr Alan,
Alan,
Alan Arkin.
Yeah.
I don't know.
And he was doing impressions and these
kids.
I said,
we got like 17 year old kids in here.
They know what you're doing.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like Joe Piscopo the three stooges.
Now they're going to know them again
because the movie.
But then I go,
first of all,
you're not even doing like at least do
shimp updated from curling.
Now he's doing.
You understand what our audience is.
So Kevin Pollak does Alan Arkin and love
was just fucking hilarious.
And he was really prepared and he was
going.
Kevin would go to say something.
They would go silence,
silence.
You impotent,
get Queer,
alcoholic,
faggot.
Trillium's doing all this shit,
you know,
they,
they bleep that out,
but you know,
just like anything he could think of to
grit down.
Yeah.
It's funny though.
So you're there for three years?
Yeah.
And it's only on directv.
It was.
Did it get on the Internet at all?
Does anybody,
anybody thinks on a website or.
No?
No,
but we're going to do a podcast.
I told you from the laugh factory.
Who you going to do it with?
Myself?
Just you?
Yeah.
Well,
unless anybody
else has available.
Brian,
you want to be in business with Brian?
Brian actually does a whole string of
podcasts.
Your podcast studio at the Ice House.
Did I do it with you?
Yeah.
You were at that point.
I know your face,
right?
You already explained that.
That xanax is a motherfucker.
Yeah,
I remember.
Was that he?
Was that today?
Earlier today.
This morning when we did the podcast.
How many of those you take one half a
day.
Is that what you know?
I'd take a three hips.
Three apps in a day?
Yeah.
How long have you been doing that?
I don't know.
Five years.
Wow.
Ever since you left me,
you son of a big difference.
I don't know.
I don't know what it's like not to take
you to.
Do you ever say,
you know what,
tomorrow I'm going to become a Vegan and
start doing yoga and drink spring water.
Go for morning jogs.
Never wanting to just jump out the
window.
No,
I don't.
I mean,
when you,
when you get ideas in your head of
moderation,
what is the,
you know,
you just go out of this.
Probably can't be good for me.
Let me just kick back a little.
Stick around a little longer.
Like what do you,
what are you thinking of when you,
when you go moderation?
Uh,
I think I only think that way when I'm
hung over and then when I'm,
when I'm normal,
I feel invincible.
Normal.
What?
I'm normal.
I mean I just feel like I could drink
and I know a little bit of booze and a
little bit of Xanax just makes you feel
great.
You just feel on top of it.
Well,
yeah.
I'm a little bit.
Does a lot of booze.
I never,
I was talking to an emergency room
doctor and she told me that the Xanax
that I take at the level I take,
it is probably a placebo at this point.
Really?
Well,
she said because you know,
you never,
I never upped the dosage because I'm not
that stupid,
you know,
and I don't want to get to a point I
never got high on Xanax.
Well,
is that what you're supposed to do?
You're supposed to continue to up the
dosage?
No,
but I think if I were an addict in the
sense of like being really addicted to
the drug and the feeling of it would be
normal to try and get higher.
I think it's just a psychological thing
that I think I needed to go back to
sleep and I'll.
Well when you hear about a guy's like
rush limbaugh and he starts doing
autopsies and you know,
you hear about them doing 99 a day and
you know,
you want to do that xanax every day and
have a drink every day.
Do you ever see that and go fuck.
Like how far away is that for when I'm
doing.
No,
you're.
You're maintaining.
Maintaining.
Yeah,
very specific.
Worry more about the booze.
I mean like I'm not into like
painkillers.
Right?
Or do you remember when I had an
operation on my balls?
What did you have done?
Your balls?
I had him.
I'm a plastic surgery to have them
reshaped and no,
I had to make them look yummy.
Dipped in chocolate.
Now I had a called a spermatocele and
it's a rupture of the sperm duck.
So your bowl starts getting bigger.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
You were at a lot of fucking pain.
But the thing that was interesting was I
never took painkillers because if you
moved
it really hurt.
But what I did was I have sophie and I
would split wine bottle of wine.
I'd rather get high on alcohol then take
Vicodin or something.
So libraries.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not really like a drug addict except
for one drug,
but not like a guy that pops pills and
fucking drinks like wildly.
I,
I'm very conservative attic.
But you,
you feel dependent on this experience,
like having this experience every day
being in that state?
Yeah.
Wow.
But I don't feel bad about it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't feel the need to correct you or
give you any advice.
You seem like a pretty resigned to it.
I'm too scared to.
You're scared of his,
his,
his Wisconsin complicated.
With your comedy comedy in your way.
I didn't get.
I don't want to say my rapier wit
turning on him.
You to go after you too hard.
No,
no,
Nah.
He needed just a beautiful.
You did what you needed to do
considering the circumstances,
how he was behaving.
He goes over the top for this show and a
lot of people don't understand that.
It's like half of it's fun.
It's to play a fucking head wound
victim.
Like him being silly.
He's like,
plays a character.
I'm playing a character.
I'm just,
I don't filter myself.
Oh,
you got to disagree with Joe.
What do you get a kick out of this
screen with the boss?
He's not quite like that.
When the camera's off.
I felt that myself.
Act Polite and sometimes he goes a
little over the top.
I'll just try trying.
It's all coming from a good place.
He's trying to get better at when to go
over the top,
but not to go over the top,
you know,
houses stand up.
That was really good.
So bad.
He's got some good jokes.
He's.
If he wanted to and he dedicated himself
to it,
he can be a real professional problem as
he's a lazy bitch.
She went here.
My Bob Hope joke.
No,
it's actually not a bad job at.
Did you hear Bob Hope died today.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They uh.
Do you think they flew out his body to
Iraq to entertain all the dead trips?
I'm not sure that a wizard job.
That's the old joe that's six years ago
and at Columbus,
Ohio funny.
But when I got booed in Harrison,
quit quit comedy for five years because
what a relief.
Damn it,
you know,
it's really hard to find them is.
And this is not to depress you.
Thirty seven.
No matter what you do,
no matter how much you work,
you'll never be as good as it was joe or
myself,
and that's sad in a way.
Well,
you could put your whole heart and so
you could get writers and you'll just
never have that natural gift.
It's not sad because I don't want that.
I don't know.
You don't have a choice?
No,
no.
I mean I,
I do comedy for a different reason.
I did call me because I think it's fun
once in a while,
but I don't obsess about it.
Like I do it once a week.
I'm good.
I don't,
it's just kind of.
Because I do so much podcasting,
I consider this like a different kind of
comedy where instead of doing like 15
people at a comedy club,
I'm doing 500,000
people,
you know,
on,
on podcast.
It is a kind of form of comedy.
You know,
I've heard people say that about posting
on message boards,
like Internet Comedians,
just like text base Internet comedians.
It is,
there's,
you know,
I'm using this template that hides in
the corner underneath the hat.
So when bidding on stage to me it
doesn't do anything for,
I don't get a boner about it like,
but I do like to be funny and silly and
Tom's old school,
he doesn't silly men in their late
thirties,
so like come up with this combined with
old school.
But he is,
he's funny.
He can be funny if you're funny.
He's just a,
he's,
he his got the man boy market covered.
Sweet.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a market.
It's out there.
Bill burr attacked it recently.
He was really upset about it and I,
and,
and I totally understand what he's
saying,
but I don't get what alternative comedy
is to me because if you go to like the
biggest alternative website,
a special thing.com.
They were talking about like Patton
Oswald's,
Sarah Silverman,
Patton Oswald.
Oswald is one of the best joke writers
that I know,
like that guy is fucking how lame live
comedy is simply a way of saying comedy
for us.
So to the people who couldn't get on
with the regular place and the people
they could,
that they worshiped like Patton Oswald,
who's great comedians.
It's like,
it's just comedy man.
You know,
the idea is that what Bursa that was so
hilarious was that they took the fear
out of comedy and they made it so
everyone's ultra supportive and he go
there and you can be like really
awkward.
And then he goes.
Meanwhile we had to go through fucking
bars.
You know,
the places that we did stand up,
we were starting out and booed at and
screened by drunks.
Yeah.
But do you believe if you're either
funny or you're not?
Yeah.
So I believe that.
I used to believe that,
but then I see people that were fucking
terrible and they stuck with it and they
figured it out.
But they learn.
You can get,
you can get to a certain point on,
on hard work,
but there's a certain point you can't
get to without talent.
Yes.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I would say yes,
but I got dammit.
I've seen people that I thought just
absolutely sucked and they figured out
how to be funny.
There were a bad.
Who's good?
Who's the best on town?
The comedian you've ever seen?
I have one.
I don't want to say I don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings.
I tell you whose name me.
Your three top comedians have excluded
that you see working right now working
today.
Doug.
Stan helps my favorite after that,
doug standpoint.
The only thing about doug is he like
angry about something.
Can't tell.
Getting.
Yeah,
of course.
I'm kidding.
How dare you.
Who else?
Louis?
Just sheer,
sheer prolific amount of amazing.
Just puts out a new hour every year.
Whose stuff's great.
I definitely have people that I like to
see that don't really necessarily stand
up
though.
Maybe alternative like Don Barris if
there's only three people that I watched
at the comedy story is funny and
everyone else I really don't watch.
It's Don Barris,
brody Stevens,
Taylor,
and do a headline set in Austin last
year when I was there for a UFC.
I didn't book a Gig.
I went to see him at the,
uh,
what is the cap city?
Just fucking great man.
He was really funny.
Norton killed any.
It was so dirty that sometimes I feel
like I have too many Dick Jokes and my
act like what is wrong with me forever.
And then I saw norton.
It was an hour solid of non peak hour
solid of his cock,
one in someone's mouth and then I
laughed.
Naturally.
Fun the entire time.
Yeah,
he's,
he's great.
Um,
depaul is great.
There's a lot of great comedians out
there right now.
Man.
This is a great time for Kelly.
Robert Bird,
Taj,
Taj and natural.
Amber has really prolific to constantly
come up and new shit.
Yeah,
there's a lot of great guys.
No,
it's a great time for comedy.
Comedy comes in waves because it was
such a dearth of talent at the store for
a long time.
And you're,
your group started up and.
Yeah,
when we came there in the nineties it
was.
You'd have these guys come up and they
were terrible.
There were people that were singing
songs and they wouldn't even have a joke
in it.
It would just be like a really,
like,
like a fucking famous hit song and they
would just sing it and yeah.
Oh,
you remember fucking what's his name?
Barry diamond.
He used to walk in and what does it
welcome in Memphis?
Memphis.
He would go on stage singing and really
singing it and then everybody will be
waiting for it to be a joke.
I told you he threatened to kill me
because he said I was stealing Zach
because some bartender in San Francisco
so that I was doing the deck.
I brought them in one night to see me.
I said,
did you see anything?
He goes,
no,
he.
Because he had asked me to help him out
or he bet he bad mouth me to the guys in
Atlanta.
Right.
And I got no beef with Barry.
And he said,
well,
if dom American headline,
why can I.
and these guys are friends of mine,
so they call them up.
Who is this fucking guy?
I said,
why would you badmouth me when you don't
know who's,
who's friends with who?
He said,
well,
I'm sorry.
Can you try and get me the GIG now?
I go,
no,
I'm not going to help you.
Now.
Community is just so scrolling.
I saw barry diamond the other day and I
actually talked to him.
We're going to do standup comedy store.
I wasn't very good.
I saw a girl,
girl,
chick,
woman,
to try to touch you or anything.
Just me on the lips.
We saw girl with Mary Lynn Rice Crop.
Yeah.
She was funny.
That's Duncan's old girlfriend.
She kicked him out and he had to live
with me.
He lived.
He lived here months.
Yeah.
Lucky bastard.
The nicest place he ever had his puppet
stay outside.
No,
I kept a puppet in my room.
I said,
I keep the puppet.
That's part of the deal.
I went Dunkin's doing great.
He's fucking killing a man.
We went on the road.
We did Louisville together.
He got a standing ovation.
Every time we went on stage.
It's crazy.
It's because of this podcast.
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah.
If you do great on the podcast,
it's fucking awesome for you.
Unfortunately,
because of this episode,
your twitter numbers are probably going
to drop really well.
People are going to unfollow you and I
shouldn't have gone into the xanax thing
if we're going to feel bad for me.
No,
you're being honest.
I think the way you're explaining it and
describing it as you are,
you're pretty logical about it.
I can't imagine not doing it.
I'm in love with it.
Without it.
What was the feeling?
What is,
when you describe anxiety,
how would you,
uh,
how would you categorize it?
Like tap,
like emotional tap,
dance,
just like jittery and always.
Well,
I don't,
I never wait man.
I never waited for the moment because
I'd always take the pills.
So when did they find on stage please
don't not come because of this stage.
You're super calm and smooth and that's
where I feel at home.
Oh,
that's crazy.
I don't feel wow.
Imagine that for most people,
getting onstage and public speaking is
one of the most terrifying things.
Joe.
Honestly,
I think my,
my pulse goes down when I'm on stage.
The only time in the last 15 years I was
ever like a little bit anxious was
Madison Square Garden would share
because I was worried about the sound
system and the people in the back nine
here in me because I heard it was a
little screwy and my sister got a little
panicky about what about me on truth,
I can't believe you get to go up in
front of all these people and that kind
of got into my head and I didn't want to
look up at the banners and stuff of the
Knicks and rangers and the history and
the garden and thinking Ali Frazier.
Sinatra was there and the Beatles were
there,
whatever,
and there's a lock up.
I was fine,
but I mean I did have a glass of wine
and I didn't.
I wanted to set to be over the first
one.
We did it two nights a second.
It's so funny how relative,
but it's because the next night if the
second set,
we were at the Pepsi Center in Denver,
which is bigger than the garden and I
thought,
oh,
it's good to be out of there.
I'm so relaxed.
I'm so relieved.
Just the history of the garden fucked
with you.
Well,
that's what it did.
Yeah.
I started letting it creep into my head.
You are,
you opened for Whitney Houston to.
Yeah.
That was not fun.
It wasn't fun.
Now,
wouldn't he know?
She never talked to me.
She had bouncers around her and I say a
prayer and I thought,
Geez,
I don't know if Jesus had 300 pound
bouncers.
Think their mostly like fisherman who
were kind of thin wafer.
And her father was a great guy and he
says,
you know,
I'm lucky to work on my daughter again.
This is really going well.
I says,
well thank you.
I'm thinking there's no way I'm working
with her again.
And she would come in late her and she
was with Bobby Brown already.
They come in one night.
I'm on stage for 45 minutes at the sands
killing and uh,
and I told the audience and says,
look,
I gotta tell you something.
She's not here.
I don't want you to think because you're
a good cook because I'm from Philly.
And it was like Lennox city.
And you know,
a lot of them knew me already and I
said,
she's not here,
I don't want to leave you in the dark.
That's why I'm staying on stage.
I'm not being self indulgent.
And they start cheering.
No,
I was really doing it for them.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And then she finally came.
But how long did he,
how long did you stay on stage?
40 slash 40 slash 50 minutes on crowd
work.
No,
I didn't do any.
Well,
was lucky that was philly though.
A place where you could do that?
It's Philly.
Well,
I mean the thing is you have to tell
them if they were upset,
you know,
I would have gotten off.
I mean,
the only time I had trouble,
uh,
with a big crowd was in Dayton,
Ohio,
because they do,
they really fucking hated me.
They hated me so much.
They came to Cleveland,
the Boomi,
he's serious,
but they couldn't get.
I see he's still here,
but you still can't get good seats that
were in the backbone.
Me,
they hated you so bad that came to
place.
Here's what happened.
Well,
I mean they're probably coming it
probably show fans coming to see her and
then generally her crowd was so eclectic
that it was easy to do stand up for it
because she doesn't get like a rock and
roll crowd.
It's not like quiet riot or something.
It's like,
you know,
she got people that push you want
academy award.
You got grandmothers with their
granddaughters and transvestites.
Yeah.
People forget she won an academy award.
She's also an emmy award.
Bad Ass straight career.
Yeah.
But uh,
so I'm up on stage and this girl starts
screaming and the crowd was really good.
Just go skirts,
store,
screaming,
share,
share.
I go,
you know,
she'll be out in a little while.
And then finally I lost my patient.
I go,
I said,
first of all,
she's not even here yet.
She changed it and put her first eyelash
one.
She's,
there's a break.
I said,
what do you,
who do you think?
I am like the friend of the owner of the
building.
I said,
I'm a comedian.
I got to do share.
I go,
listen,
you stupid son of a bitch.
You think I'm gonna?
I'm gonna lift up the curtain shoe to
come out and sing for you fucking idiot.
And then the crowds and then I went
after her and I just started at one
after another and then the crowd start
booing.
Well I got upset with me and I go,
Hey,
I'm sorry,
but she's fucking annoying,
you know,
and that was my only really bad
experience and it's pretty tough when
you lose an arena.
It ain't like we lose in 300 people at a
comedy club and getting them back.
When you lose an arena,
like to let the.
Well it's a real problem when no one
wants to see you,
then they're there to see some.
Let's see.
She put me on the bill,
which really made it classy.
Wasn't like,
you know,
special guests or anything.
It was like dom opening act.
That's what happened to Kurt Fox
recently with Charlie Sheen.
Remember that?
Watch the video.
They gave him a chance.
He a dick up there.
No,
I disagree.
I watched it.
They weren't yet.
No,
I'm saying that they weren't really dare
to see him.
They were,
they were down,
they gave him a chance,
they gave him a chance and he didn't
come with any jokes that that's not,
that's not what happened in that
situation.
I think curt will admit to that he
just didn't work well when we had him on
the podcast.
A I sort of an ironic sense of humor and
he's a.
he's got a good delivery,
but I think he requires a,
an attentive audience.
Yeah,
but he also said on the podcast we had a
death squad that that when he came out
that the people didn't know what to
expect and so he came out and just
started doing comedy and people
immediately when you came out,
start going,
who books with Ms Dot troubleshooting.
That's a big difference.
Yeah.
Well that's him being a rookie in these.
Sheena.
Some dudes just sitting there talking.
That's what you were saying.
That's him being a rookie.
You have to address that.
You're hired as a comedian to go on
stage in front of Charlie Sheen and no
one knows what the fuck is going on.
This is the first show you guys have
done and that's what happened.
You got to go onstage and you go,
you got to set them up.
I don't know what the Fuck Charles is
going to do it.
I think there was one.
I like Tennessee want to handle that or
something like that,
but it's really at this stage
who's here to say Charlie Sheen?
Yeah,
I mean it's really bad if you're not on
the bill.
Yeah,
it's very classy and we share was
classy.
You know stacy,
the dame had Claire C and I think there
was something else that like they were
waiting.
They were waiting for a long time and I
was really late and I'm sure,
I'm sure there's a lot of that,
but you know,
you've got to learn how to use.
If you're going to open for a guy like
that,
you have to have some fucking rock solid
material.
Or what did he think was going to
happen?
Joe,
what did you think was gonna happen when
I was going to write an act that
quickly?
Well,
that's what he wants to it.
What do you want to do?
And his brain comedians with them,
I know Russell Peters did a couple of
them.
We did Toronto with them and a few other
places I think as well.
And they would go up on stage and
Russell would sit down with them and
Charlie would interview.
Yeah,
Russell would interview Charlie.
Oh,
talk to them and then crack a bunch of
jokes along the way and you know,
Russell's great at that shit.
So Russell,
so fucking funny.
He's a great guy,
great guy.
And he's a,
you know,
it's so funny.
Every time I sit next to an Asian
person,
I mean I'm talking about Asia from
Cambodia to Pakistan.
I always asked him to in a Russell
Peters,
if we're forgetting to talk,
if they asked me what I do and they all
know,
wow,
talk about one continent to pick the.
Get to watch your back Asia to.
He sold out the o two arena,
I think it was two nights in a row in
London.
That's what they did.
The UFC do the UFC there,
Russell.
That the coolest thing about him is that
he constantly surprises me.
Like he,
he,
there's this guy named polly,
he's like this big twitter guy and he
just gave them a chance like,
hey,
why don't you come out to Arizona?
And then he did the same thing to a door
guy who Jesus over at the comedy store
just grabbed them,
was like,
hey,
he was one of the guys that I came to a
dead mouse.
The studio that night he opened for him
in Irvine.
He brings a mitogen on the road with
them too.
Yeah.
He just grabs people and it gives them
chances a lot.
Like just random guys.
I know.
It's really neat.
Yeah.
Russell is a real good dude.
He's a real good dude.
There's a lot of good people in comedy.
You know,
it's an interesting thing about
comedians and becoming friends with a
bunch of them and you know,
it's like have to get the greatest
people to communicate with,
you know,
cracks me up when people don't know that
we're really friends.
Like they think we're in constant
competition.
My competition is with me trying to get
better.
It's like somebody said to me,
I don't mean to offend you,
but I really like Robin Williams.
I said,
well,
you're allowed to.
Like I said,
what do you think somebody even said
that about or about?
You know,
I just wanted to say I think he's funny.
I don't mean to offend you.
Offend me.
I think he's funny too.
I think he's great.
I go,
what do you think?
I think I carry comedy on my back and it
had there you insult me by liking
another comedian.
It'd be a lot of
pressure.
Him.
You've always been a supporter of
comedians.
You were always great.
You gave me great advice when,
when I was first coming up with the
store.
You always,
always when somebody have a good set,
you would always be like really a
complimentary and you know,
talk to them about what you really
liked.
Some communities I'll do that shit.
So committees,
they never good.
Never go up to a young guy and give him
props.
I mean I'd love to fucking.
And
when you did that,
when Joe,
your face,
when you did new rules are and of course
Mary Joe is one of the funniest,
I swear to God,
your neck got longer.
That was a bid that we,
new rules
can not work and eat it and kill.
And that was a bit.
It took a long time.
I remember coming up and telling you
that because it me,
I was fucking crying.
New rules.
The 90 year old that I had to work.
I worked on that bid for a fucking year.
That was one of those bits that just,
I just kept tweaking it.
I could never get it right.
Yeah.
No,
I just,
I knew there was something in this just
like my diamonds size.
But Damn,
you only opened up with it today.
You're going to be fine.
What do you got?
Their fellow?
Yeah,
I want to.
Energy drinks.
Yeah.
We're going to wrap this thing up.
So it's almost two hours in.
So where are you going to be next time?
I'll be at the hilarity next week and
then two weeks I'll be.
Was it 25th?
I think captain.
Brian's 25th,
26th and you're on twitter.
Dom Irrera I r e r r a on twitter.
She was really nice meeting you,
Tom.
We already knew each other.
It was nice hanging out with you.
Oh,
okay.
Good.
Does anybody have any more xanax before
we go?
Do you feel weird about revealing that
to the world?
No,
I don't know.
You don't care?
I don't give a fuck.
That's the only.
The only thing.
The only reason I would like to be gay
is just to come out.
They don't give a fuck,
but I mean I'm not gay because I like
women so much but it would be like I was
thinking about it even at this point,
the way I look now and this is what's
great about show business and you know,
is that I couldn't be gay if I wanted to
because I couldn't ever get guys as good
looking as the girls like it because
guys are more superficial and into.
But you can get girls because they like
talent and money.
No.
So anyway,
the guy who,
the guy who got thrown back into the
closet,
we don't need you out here.
That's funny.
I would like to be gay just so I can
come out just so you can say it.
You don't give a fuck where you
surprised when Kevin,
me and he came out.
It was like in his fifties show how many
per.
There's only a certain amount.
There's only a certain amount of show
tunes you can sing.
Not Be gay.
I was surprised with todd glass.
I was as well.
You weren't surprised but I have a thing
on my phone of tagless talking to me.
They'll let you hear drunk.
No,
no,
no.
He,
I offended him and he called to
reconcile it and the Florida radio
station called me to bust his balls and
I didn't realize what I was saying was.
And I like todd.
I would never want to hurt him,
but I was saying that he says you never
thought I was funny,
didn't you?
I said I always thought you were funny.
I mean not like laugh out loud.
Funny.
But you know,
like he never going to go in and see it
to go.
My stomach hurts.
But you know,
you were funny.
I mean you liked these,
the Tuesday,
Wednesday and Sunday headliner,
you know,
and I didn't know it but that's what he
was doing that weekend.
I was crushing him and he's a very
sensitive guy and if he hears just be,
here's this.
I love him.
But I was just joking around.
They didn't know I was hitting on some
pumps,
sore points,
you know,
todd glass called me up after them and
see if things somehow or another we got
on the phone together and he was one,
oh,
like,
you know,
a lot of comedians were happy after that
went down.
But todd and I really didn't know each
other very well and he was so
enthusiastic and happy and he just said
thank you.
Thank you.
Just thank you for doing it.
And he dropped to his knees.
I'm glad now in retrospect that I didn't
give a big long hug and both of my
parents are retired and go crazy.
Both of my parents are care,
gay recharge.
But,
you know,
there was a few people that were
fascinated by it,
but he was super thankful and I talked
with,
you know,
um,
kindler and I briefly said,
you know,
we're like maybe there should be some
sort of a fucking comedians union,
you know,
it shouldn't be a union.
They tried it,
they tried it in New York with the was.
But that was about like pay at the
clubs,
right?
Is that what it was about?
No,
no,
it was past that it was about a health
insurance and joining a unionized.
But it's tough when everybody's in
competition with each other for,
for jobs.
I think the only place it would work is
if you know,
when you have to get rid of fees that,
that,
that is when having comedians together,
like people don't understand the issue
behind thievery.
And that's why there was a lot of people
that thought that what I did was really
douchey and when we released that Carlos
video,
but when you have someone who is being
unchecked and they're doing well and
they're just running through the comedy
world,
like people don't understand what that's
like.
It's like you're working with someone
who just might steal your car and no one
else that you work with is going to do
shit about it.
The guy just going to steal your car.
I mean,
really that what it's like a joke is
actually worth more than A.
Hey,
how about this?
How about Bob Hope Joke.
We're at the fucking.
We're at the,
uh,
word,
the Jerry's Deli today.
He launched into chick came over and
quoted one of your jokes.
I mean,
think about that joke.
That's a fucking 15,
20 year old joke,
right?
Let me think about how much that's
worth,
that's worth more than a car to somebody
could just get exhausted.
Hospital happened and what we're reading
so someone could just gag that.
They could just steal that right in
front of you.
And we had like a real problem with.
We've got a problem with a couple of
guys at the store when you watched that
shit happen and you know,
you've seen it all.
We've all seen it happen several times
throughout our career.
A guy who comes along,
it's just a fucking buccaneer who just
grabbing them from all over the place
and nobody wants to do anything about
it.
That's the time where I think something
like a comedy union would help,
you know,
we,
we could all get together and just all
of us unanimously say,
Ladies and gentlemen of the audience,
you people out there that,
that paint see,
stand up comedy.
This guy's a fucking thief and this is
just what it is.
Signed by Rera,
Tim Allen,
blah,
blah blah.
You know what I say to an obscure
reference to pull out the will of people
I never even heard you mentioned him and
I think I left and I never have met him
once.
He was a nice guy,
very nice guy.
Went on stage at the comedy store is
doing a joke about his Ferrari breaking
down.
That's something everybody can relate to
her.
Yeah.
It pissed me off because I had to drive
my mazur roddy that day and I hate that
it was sticking it in your face.
Dom Dom had a cadillac once where he put
a vinyl roof on it.
You know,
when you get one of those nice smushy
roofs,
it might have been one of the last ones
made in America.
Like you have the cabinet in the.
You had the roof put on.
I remember you like,
I think I'm going to get a nice soft is
such a fucking awesome Guinea move and
I,
I embrace so many things Guinea.
But I thought it was hilarious that you
were doing that.
I was like,
Yay,
go for it.
I want to get a pinky ring to fucking
boom.
Bada boom by each other.
You know,
you,
you and you went and you got it done.
Yeah.
That he had a nice cadillac and yet the
back end.
You had a nice a vinyl roof put on like
this.
It looks classier.
Remember when cars had those brawls at
the front that you used to be a big
super close super leather,
but borrow.
A friend of mine had an a Mazda rx
seven.
One of the fucking cool years,
like with the flip up headlights and
shit and he had abroad.
I was like,
that might be the dopest cowell time.
Mazda had a hell of a car in that rx
seven to like one of the last models
right around the time where accurate
came out with the NSX around that other
and Toyota came out with the supra is
you're not in the cards.
John Merera doesn't even have a
navigation system.
How about that?
Well,
I tell them I wouldn't be able to figure
it out anyway.
You're burning it up and so reduce.
Susie has the navigation.
Then he used to have as far as like you
have.
I mean my God,
they're incredible and I'm fucking
terrorize being with driving around.
You go from point a to point B in 60
minutes.
It's unbelievable and I was getting like
jeeves from getting thrown back,
but I tried to act normal heads hitting
the thing,
but the most cathartic thing about this
whole experience was I finally got to
tell you,
I was afraid of the pimples.
I told you without reason,
I never wanted you to think and I never
had the heart to tell you that I didn't
want to come to your house.
Not a pushy person.
No,
but I mean,
you know,
there's always a need coming into
Hollywood shooting pool with me.
There was no.
It's nice to get that off my chest.
Just finally admitted that even that
they were shooting and those doors were
just walking around.
Just solid muscle and teeth.
Fucking jaws of death.
Ernest sweeties.
I believe that,
but there's always that.
One time I will wait to meet Johnny
cash.
Johnny cash is my master.
He's a sweetheart.
Oh,
he's outside.
He's nice dog.
He's way bigger than the pimples,
so maybe I met him another time blocking
you.
That's a big dog.
I made them another.
He's so strong.
It's ridiculous.
I've never had a dog that's as strong as
him.
It's a dog where you read.
Like if he lunges for something,
I got a drop down and dig in with both
my feet and hang on a horse.
See,
here's the problem.
He's going to know I'm afraid of him.
No,
he's a sweetheart.
But he knows.
They sense it.
Yeah,
but trust me,
he's going to go right from my mastiffs
is they're very confident because
they're not worried about you at all
masters and never worried about a person
beating their ass.
They just the headmasters,
because they're so confident,
they're so big and so strong.
They are very nice,
like they don't.
They're not insecure.
Like there's certain certain dogs that
feel like they have to establish
dominance over person or scare a person.
Mastiffs.
They're not like that.
If they're barking at you,
it's real.
If a massive is angry at you and
barking,
you better realize you gotta fucking
real problem because a dog that's that
big.
You're talking about 150 to 200 pound
dog.
Do you know how strong that fucking let
those dogs and with the kids.
Of course,
yeah,
we play with the kids,
but that I'm sure enough to have them
around kids.
If you can't trust the dog around kids,
you can't have that dog.
My Dog's exhibit.
No aggression.
You have two masters?
No.
The other one's a bulldog mix.
He's a very lazy dog,
but he's a sweetheart too.
They're both real nice dogs,
man.
Joe,
do you know anything about the Honda Crx
z?
Is that that a hybrid thing?
Hybrid.
I saw one the other day and it was
amazing.
It looked like a spaceship go.
Have you seen what they're doing now in
a car?
They're putting stitcher in a gang of
cars.
Going to be in BMW's.
BMW's.
It's forward.
It's a all the big guys and now they
also have three g on here and like,
like I said the other day,
this new ipad has the four g light on
it.
Verizon,
yeah.
It's faster than my business clash.
A charter at my studio.
That's incredible.
I've got four G,
a car that I put in my laptop.
I'm pretty happy with it.
When you actually get a four g
connection on the road.
It's a little sketchy though,
but it's always better than the shit
that's in the hotel room if you've seen.
Well,
first of all,
let's talk about their fucking virus
that we both thought we got.
Yeah,
so don't know.
It's the flashback virus.
If you're using a Mac and you think that
you can't get a Trojan,
it's not really a virus.
It's a Trojan.
It's an exploit through Java and it's a
guess.
It only works if you don't have your
Java updated to the latest and greatest.
Yeah.
If you.
If you're one of those people that keep
your shit updated,
you,
you're really not going to have to worry
about it.
That though.
I wouldn't say that.
Also,
it's also it's,
it's only if you go to some really
sketchy website,
the more I read about it and also just a
way to test it to see if you have it and
I tested mine and I go to the filthiest
fucking places in the world and I didn't
have it.
I mean I did look at torrent websites.
What do you do?
You open up terminal and you have to cut
and paste this.
A couple of different lines of code in
it.
The easiest way to to actually figure it
out.
If you go to a nine to five.com,
our Mac nine to five.com.
What is that website,
right Mac?
Nine to five.
It was if you just googled Mac virus
will come up with a couple pages and
there's links to the code that you cut
and paste into your browser and it's a
nine to five Mac.com
is the one that I saw at on and it's
pretty much you just type in these codes
and if you don't,
if it,
it tells you what to look for and what
not to look for to tell you if you have
it.
But you know,
honestly,
the only thing you really have to do is
just open up your little apple on the
left hand corner,
hit,
uh,
hit it and then go to system update and
there's a Java update,
uh,
in that if you have that,
we'll patch it.
And if it's not in there already,
I mean check to make sure you have it.
Then you must have already done some
people say you shouldn't have Java on
your browser.
You should enabled the problem.
The problem is is yeah,
well when you go to any kind of,
when you first get your laptop,
when you first get your Mac,
that's the one of the first things that
comes up.
It's like,
would you like to Install Java?
Like is not a part of the operating
system is not a part of windows.
It's a third party thing that you add to
your browser.
Pretty much.
So it's a plugin.
Like I just had it turned off on this
laptop over here and I tried to go to
that Honda website and it didn't work.
The Honda website didn't work because I
didn't have a job enabled so I enabled
it.
Now it works.
I checked the,
this laptop and his Mac or this Imac.
You updated it last night.
So it's everything's cool and it's.
If you're looking at.
If you go to nine to five Mac.com
and you look at the map that,
that like who's infected,
you know there is a lot of people
infected but this is,
we're talking about rural to Ra
worldwide.
Will did.
Rolled Don verus say that he had
someone,
Don dot Mary's had a meltdown last night
on the stage because he had his facebook
hacked and his gmail hack.
So then he went in there and changed all
this shit and then they hacked it again
and he pretty much on stage was like,
you know what I give up.
I'm not putting my,
I'm not doing any more podcasts anymore.
I'm not,
I'm done with this Dingdong shut.
Like it really freaked him out that
people.
These are the freaking mountain dom.
You Got Xanax farm.
Well it's,
it's,
it's the point that I mean like,
like we were talking about this the
other day.
So if a,
if an ex girlfriend finds your cell
phone and looks through your cell phone,
that scary sometimes like you don't know
what you fucking say to your friends are
like,
you know,
do you should've just kidding.
Maybe not.
Yeah.
Oh well it's like a I,
if I ever die,
my parents find my fucking laptop and
they have to go through it and sort of.
That's the most scary shit ever.
My Mom's gonna be like,
what's wrong,
Brian?
And then it can't be like,
mom.
No,
I downloaded those for photoshop so I
could put joe's face on it and it's an
honest message board.
You know what I mean?
Like choke pitchers are really into
black day.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think of that when I'm jerking off on
the couch and there's porns leapt out if
I died,
like who would walk in and see what,
you know,
how perverted they aren't.
Yeah,
exactly.
So now imagine,
imagine the whole Internet being able to
do that to your computer,
not your mom,
not your fucking girlfriend.
Looking at your phone.
Now imagine the whole Internet being
able to access your computer.
That's fucking terrifying.
It was terrifying.
Yeah,
it's going to happen.
I really think that,
you know,
we talked about,
uh,
with everlast the other day,
we're like secrets or on the way out at
a certain point in time,
everything you do online,
someone's going to be able to read it.
Someone's going to be able to listen to
your phone calls are going to be able to
access.
That's what I said last night.
I was like,
Joe,
you know,
there's like at least seven people in
New Zealand right now listening to this
phone call that are ahead of us in
technology that can.
It's probably boring tiger woods with a
great example,
like when I was a kid,
baseball players,
they'll cheat on their wives,
but the sports writers knew what they
didn't.
They didn't rat him out.
But today's world,
you know,
they traced down everything.
Yeah.
You know,
and he wouldn't,
he wouldn't even been in trouble.
What Michael Jordan probably did is,
you know,
double that.
I mean Michael Jordan in his prime
goddamn tornado sweeping white women
through the air like semis.
Could you see that?
A video footage of Dallas,
the fucking tornado hitting Dallas and
semis were flying through the air like
paper Dom 18 wheelers full 18.
We're lose 30,
40,
50 feet in the air,
just spinning in circles.
It's fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
It's really weird to watch,
man.
I would highly recommend.
Now,
uh,
this is something that I'm personally
going to start doing,
is to take your fucking computer and
empty it all out onto external hard
drives.
And then unplug those external hard
drives from your computer and only use
them when you need to or make him.
Yeah,
but I mean it only takes it like if,
if people are hacking Max and people are
doing this shit now they feel like wiki
leaks and all this fucking crazy shit.
If you really want to fucking protect
these woody,
the government.
Well I mean I think hackers are way
above what we know that they are.
You know,
I think people are downloading fucking
large amounts of information about
anyone.
I think there's fucking message boards
that people probably go,
all right,
who should we look at their computer
today?
Oh,
let's go to a seat.
Steven Seagal is,
let's see this new thing on the
cover of wired.
This month's wired about the NSA
building,
like the most incredible security spying
computer system ever where they're going
to be able to literally keep a data
record of every phone call you make
every text you send,
every,
every phone call to get out.
I mean,
could you just stop and imagine that
the,
the ability to record every single phone
call that gets made throughout the
entire country all the time.
Well doesn't like when we,
when the Dell is a dell,
there's a big computer somewhere that
has all these information on it for
years.
And then finally it gets thrown out.
Like everything we did,
everything we did on the computer is
stored somewhere.
That's what I've heard.
I have no.
I have no backup.
Guys would agree with Newton cars.
Brian,
you're getting so bored with this
podcast,
by the way.
Now I'm doing Cleveland,
let's say,
and it's long doing Cleveland this week.
Oh,
this week.
I'm kidding.
Next week.
They're cheap too.
Not saying it's long.
I get it.
That was a joke.
Yeah.
Dom,
Joe,
come love.
Love you buddy.
Boy.
Fucking buying cars online over here.
I'm going to price it just.
Well,
I just wanted to know how much I saw
today and I really was.
Cool.
Impulsivity child can stay off a
website.
This God damn podcast.
Get this guy's on Xanax.
You're on marijuana.
I'm on marijuana and coconut water.
C,
two is delicious by the way.
It is,
right?
Isn't it one of your sponsors?
No,
not really.
They're all friends though.
See Two.
Oh,
it's the best was white.
coconut water.
So delicious is because uh,
it comes from Thailand and they have a
very specific,
uh,
like it's a small boutique company,
very specific type of coconut.
It's,
it's a small tree to apparently show.
Can you go over your sponsors for the
meeting one more time?
I can,
but before that I will tell you Atlanta
for 20 the tabernacle.
I'm recording my fucking special bitches
first show.
Sold out this second.
Yeah.
Second show.
Almost sold out.
Cool.
There's a couple hundred six.
I'm not going to lie to do you know,
a couple hundred seats left.
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's a huge place,
but there's plenty of tickets.
Go get them.
Jump on it.
It's Joe.
He's terrific laws and Shit I've ever
done.
You know how good I am with numbers?
It's amazing.
Like for instance,
Cleveland Hilarides there,
number two,
one,
six,
seven,
three,
six,
four,
two,
four.
Two had written down your motherfucking.
I didn't,
I wasn't looking.
I was,
I was depressed for your ride of a bit
smarter as it wouldn't sneak a plugin.
Dom,
what exact days?
You there?
Next Wednesday.
The twelfth.
He while he gave him the phone number.
Where's the Goddamn website?
That's.
This is 2012.
My website.
What is their website?
Oh,
hilarity.
So no,
but I know mine does [inaudible] dot
com.
Tom,
I remember I r e r r a r r e r a r r e
R.
All right.
And I'll be with ideas and May 17th in
Columbus,
Ohio.
And Pittsburgh if you got a desktop.
R E R,
r A.
There's two r's in the beginning.
The beginning?
Yeah,
I r,
R,
e r a all that's it.
Next week.
Florida Improv a April.
What is it?
13.
Which one?
Joe?
Uh,
Fort Lauderdale.
Oh,
I love the club.
I'll be there in September.
I'm tightening up for this tabernacle
show in which is the following week.
So I'm two weeks out.
So next Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday I will stop that next Friday,
Saturday and Sunday I'll be in Fort
Lauderdale with Duncan trussell and
data.
That's the power push up until the final
week.
And that,
uh,
that would be the week of the 20th.
April 20th,
Atlanta at the Tabernacle.
I'm going to film it,
edit it,
release it all online myself.
Oh Man.
Got a whole new website coming.
I'm,
I'm ready to rock and roll with this
thing.
I'm very excited.
It's the best shit I've ever done too.
And I could have done a special about a
year ago.
So this is,
I think is my best stuff ever because
it's real tight and it's been more than
two years since my last one.
So I'm coming out guns blazing bitches.
So check us in the Fort Lauderdale
Improv.
That's next week.
The 13th,
14th and 15th.
Me and Duncan trussell.
And then the week after that,
the Tabernacle in Atlanta,
Joe Rogan.net.
For more details,
thank you to the flashlight for
sponsoring our podcast.
Please go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
flashlight.
And during the code name Brogan and you
can get 15 percent off the number one
sex toured furman.
Brian podcast Friday.
Yes.
Ice House.
Doug Benson.
Freddy Lockhart.
Do you have a show show?
We did a show at the ice house with Doug
Benson.
Joe Diaz.
Jason Teebo.
He did.
Joey did.
I said Doug Benson,
Benson,
and mindset.
But it's going to be a hell of a Goddamn
show and it sells out quick as it's only
85 seats.
Oh,
are you doing the other room?
When are we going to do that other room
again?
That was fun.
Have the main room.
We'll try to do that again.
That's hard to get them.
Yeah,
that was good.
We gotta get that Shit.
Will look at it in advance.
What's hard to get a last minute main
room at ice house.
That shit in advance.
Isotope you.
You do the Ice House right to the club.
I love that club.
We do a podcast.
They're often regular basis.
You were there at dom?
I wasn't.
I'd like to stop in when you're there,
man.
Come on down sir.
You there?
Friday?
What are you doing this Friday?
I know I already got two spots.
Friday.
Where?
What time left factory in the store.
What time response?
Ten and 11 something.
Oh Wow.
Throwing you late.
Well,
no,
I wouldn't.
I'd put it in for late sleep in sleep
until my.
Alright,
so that's it.
My cousin John Wagner,
they're doing a scholarship thing for
him in Philly when the 21st of April.
So look on twitter and I'll put a post
to your twitter,
twitter,
I r,
r,
e are a fucking retarded dom.
I rarely show thanks to [inaudible] dot
com o n n it.
Go check out alpha brain,
new mood.
Shroom Tech Sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune and go get yourself some money
off by using the code name.
Rogan.
You'll save yourself 10 percent off all
orders already.
Dirty freaks.
We'll see you tomorrow with Jim
Jefferies.
It will be starting with you starting
around 5:00
PM Pacific coast time because Jim has a
show out this this way.
He's going to be at the Canyon Club
tomorrow night.
If you don't know and you live in a Gore
hills,
go check out one of the tops standups in
the country right now.
Jim Jefferies,
the Australian lad,
and he's gonna be he's gonna.
Be here tomorrow.
He'll tell you all about it,
so don't miss tomorrow.
We love you and we'll see you soon.
Bye Bye now.
Thank you joe.
Thank you dom.